Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. No else,
you posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic
for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those
clever finished founders,
and when I first mentioned
that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week
at lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite
side of the spectrum and new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir
to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for
decades. I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey
brain has never been easy,
still isn't easy very often,
and I found Reishi,
which I've been fascinated by for
a few years now, has been very,
very effective and calming
their old formula. However,
four sigmatic old formula included
Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons,
and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with
this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without
sweeteners if you'd be open to it,
if too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game
for experimentation.
And so they created a special
custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio elixir comes
in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel and in fact
I'm about to leave the country right
now and I have a packet in front of me
that's just going to sit in the end of my
carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy
that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and then
I'll give you my take quote.
A warning for those in the experimental
mindset ratio is strong and bitter in
parentheses, like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or
nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say no,
you should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter.
And maybe you should take the advice
of all Chinese people when they're
criticizing ins. When they
say Boone, I'm sure cool.
Which means you're not
able to eat bitterness.
Bitter is in many cases and indication
of things that help liver detoxification
and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio
lecture on family members,
on friends. Everybody has liked it. It's
a little bit earthy. It's not that hard.
So I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put in honey or milk or any of
that shit. Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious I think. Right? If you
like [inaudible], that kind of stuff,
that type of tea, you're going
to dig it. So just try it. Okay.
Back to then my read. If you'd like
to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset end quality, I think
naturally you might just enjoy this.
Reishi Elixir without any sweeteners.
It has organic, Reishi extract,
organic fueled, mint extract, organic
rose hips extract, organic Tulsi extract.
And that's it.
No fancy stuff,
no artificial watching McCall at anything.
So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash
and Ferris and get 20% off this special
batch. I don't know if they're gonna
be making much more of this, uh,
it since it was made specifically for
you guys to do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be
open to experimenting with
me to create products for
you guys. Specifically, check it out.
Four sigmatic, that's Flur, s, I, g,
m, a t, I c.com forward
slash Ferris, F, e R, r, I s,
s and get 20% off the special batch and
you must use the code Ferris to receive
a discount. F, e R, R, I s. S. So again,
going to foursigmatic.com forward slash
Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20%
off of this rare exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir
for nighttime routines with out any
sweeteners.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to
you by helix sleep. Last year,
I committed to making
sleep a top priority,
trying to fix onset insomnia or
continuing to fix that depth of sleep,
quality of sleep.
I tracked a lot.
I tested a lot and I revisited really
everything from the daily routine to the
surfaces. I slept on playing
with the chilly pad, whatever,
and when I moved to
Austin I got all new beds,
including mattresses from Helix,
working with the world's leading
sleep experts. Certainly some of them.
He looks sleep developed mattresses
personalized to your preferences and sleep
style to make sure that you can have
the best sleep possible without costing
thousands upon thousands of dollars.
He looks sleep has recently added a new
layer to customize sleep with the helix
pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position or body type,
or if you're a shifty type like me,
I move around quite a bit when I sleep.
Just take their simple two to three
minute sleep quiz to get started and that
will help ensure that they can build a
mattress or pillow that you will love the
mattress, whatever this be spoke,
mattresses that you arrive at a,
we'll get to you within a week and
the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress for 100 nights
and if you're not completely happy,
they'll pick it up and
offer a full refund.
I tested that refund policy because I
test all of these sponsors and kick the
tires a lot.
We tested it and they came through and
making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body.
Type to personalize your sleep experience,
visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you'll
receive up to $125 your mattress order
that's helix sleep,
h,
e l I x sleep.com forward slash
Tim for up to $125 off your order.
Why?
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
[inaudible],
my beautiful little [inaudible] this show,
as some of you may know, is about
deconstructing world class performers,
teasing out the habits, routines, life
lessons, thought processes, frameworks,
and so on from people in
many different industries,
many different areas of expertise that
you can hopefully apply to your own lives.
And my guest today is Steve Jurvetson
who really has his hand in many,
many different worlds. You can say
hello to him on Twitter at DFJ. Steve,
he is a venture capitalists,
but a lot more than that
focused on founder led mission
driven companies at the
cutting edge of disruptive technology.
Now you might think to yourself,
well that's what I might hear
many venture capitalists say,
but he was recommended to me
by a past guest as a guest,
Matt Mullenweg who I trust
very implicitly. And uh,
to give you an idea of the street cred,
he has been the founding venture capital
investor in for public companies and
many rapidly growing companies
like planet Memphis, meats,
mythic and Nirvana and e r. V. Nirvana.
He also led investments in startups that
were later collectively acquired for
$12 billion.
Probably much more at this point.
Before cofounding the firm,
DFJ draper Fisher,
Jurvetson Steve was a r and d
engineer at Hewlett Packard,
worked in product marketing
at apple and next many,
many stories about his mentors there and
then spent a short stint in management
consulting at Bain.
He completed his electrical engineering
degree at Stanford and two and a half
years.
Think about that for a second.
Graduating number one in his class and
went on to earn all sorts of degrees,
MSW, NBA, et cetera.
In 2016 President Barack Obama appointed
Steve as a presidential ambassador for
global entrepreneurship.
Steve was also chosen as one of tech's
best venture investors and quote by
Forbes and as the venture capitalist
of the Europe by Deloitte. Steve,
we'll be launching a brand new venture
fund sometime later this year and you can
read about it@future.ventures,
so not future.com but future.ventures.
That's how you would spell it out.
Not surprisingly,
he will be focusing on passionate
founders who are on a mission to make the
world a better place with a penchant
for unique ideas and disruptive
technologies.
And disruptive may be an overused term,
but Steve really understands what that
means and we dig into some very, very,
very specific examples that might make
your mind explode. So without further ado,
please enjoy this wide ranging
conversation with Steve Jurvetson.
Steve,
welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Come here.
I am looking here at all my notes when
you were kind enough to send links to
various resources,
interviews, discussions,
and I have to tell you I feel a little
overwhelmed because usually I have
someone on the shell.
It's like, all right,
we have person a and they're
really good at rock climbing.
I think we'll start with rock climbing
and in this case we're not even going to
cover 10% of the notes that I have in
front of me and they've already been
winnowed down.
But there is,
I think one story that I came upon that
I'd love for you to describe for people
just as a starting point and it's a quote
and then you can give the background
from Professor David Deutsch out
of Oxford. And it begins with,
and please correct me if I'm wrong,
the only way this computer can be
as powerful as it is dot, dot, dot.
What does this quote? Sure. Um,
and I may be paraphrasing cause it's,
uh, stuff you wrote back in 2002,
2001 at least I read the book fabric or
valid in 2002 and he's talking about the
power of quantum mechanics and the
potential for quantum computers.
And in so doing,
he and Richard Fineman both realized that
a quantum computer to be fundamentally
unlike anything we have
in this world today. Uh,
and the way that quote roughly ends is
that the only way to explain the power of
these computers is to invoke the
notion that it is sort of engaging the
resources across parallel universes.
That if you just use the
resources of one university,
now there's so much you can do.
But in this case,
you actually are in the most poetic sense,
harnessing almost refractive echoes
across apparel universities to do
computation in a
fundamentally different way.
And that usually bends the
mind of most scientists,
even physicists to the point of
breaking or looking the other way.
And the common response to this is,
I don't understand one bit of
that and it had me captivated.
So I want to jump into a number of
areas that I know nothing about or very
little about,
even though I might use the
words occasionally as people
who spent a lot of time
in silicon valley are,
are want to do,
but for people who don't
have the background,
I want to highlight a few things
about you or actually one,
just as we're delving into
some of the science. Sure.
So your background or a lot of
your background is engineering.
So electrical engineering,
I tried doing bachelor's and master's
and started a phd and you were able to do
so much of that partially because you
finished your Undergrad in two and a half
years. That's right. Okay. The
point I wanted to make with that,
and we're gonna come back to that because
I don't know how that even happens, uh,
is that you have technical literacy,
but also learning like a child.
Right?
So can you walk us through one of the
terms I was hoping to understand for
myself and that is quantum computing.
What is a quantum computer, right? Uh,
a quantum computer is a device.
It's usually something that is either
cooled down to almost absolute zero or has
some other phenomenon that
it takes advantage of that
is at the edge of what is
the known universe.
Meaning when you cool something to zero,
behavior of materials changes
dramatically if you have a superconductor.
The way it works is dramatically
different from normal conductors.
And so what people have found is that
rather than look at quantum mechanics as
something that is spooky and bizarre the
way a Albert Einstein even described it,
this spooky action at a distance,
this ability to entangle things to have
them to have their fates intermingled
can be not just used for things like
really unbreakable cryptography and data
transmission. It could also be used in
a very bizarre way to build a computer.
And this computer,
it looks something like a row of let's
say rings that are either magnetically in
one direction or the other. You can
think of it in a traditional computer,
it's a one or a zero,
but actually it can be everything
in between simultaneously.
Much like when you dive into
how an Adam actually works,
there isn't an electron any given point.
It's a cloud.
It's a probability function
around the Adam. Well,
that cloud is something we're
not used to in the real world.
We're used to the statistical aggregation
of many items and it's like there's a
table. It's hard. I can't put
my hand through the table.
It's not sometimes here and sometimes
over there, but the farther down you look,
the closer and closer to,
let's say the atomic scale,
you notice the behavior of physics becomes
quantum physics and rather than being
something spooky,
you can actually harness this to
compute in a very peculiar way,
in a way that in a very,
in a very simple level,
you could say it's as if all of your
memory bank and the computer was a one and
a zero simultaneously. So you
instantly jump or tunnel to the answer.
You're looking forward
to particular problem.
So rather than exhaustively searching
millions or billions or trillions of
possibilities to find, let's say the
key that unlocks it digital lock,
you just jump to the answer.
That's a seemingly science fiction.
But these,
these computers do exist. Yes. Um, and
even within scientific communities,
there's some backbiting that says, well
wait, do they really exist as this one?
An example is that just
a fast analog computer?
So it is at the edge of a what
people believe is possible. And uh,
I think we actually need literally
at this period of history where these
computers are starting to come out.
I've been on the board of directors
of one for Gosh over 15 years now.
So I was a little early and thinking
when this was ready for prime time.
It's now at the point where,
for example,
Google says that their quantum computer
that they bought from a company called D
wave outperforms,
they're entitled to entire data center
on certain computational tasks and that
are important to what they do.
And other tasks that are meant
to really show how fast is it.
They found 100 million fold speed up over
the best computer they could buy from
anyone else.
How big is such a quantum computer?
They're almost all about the same size.
Not because the computer is big,
but because the cooling apparatus and the
shielding from me that it flux is high.
So thinking about a refrigerator size,
slightly bigger like two refrigerators,
the actual computer is just done a little
silicon ship that's as small as any
other silicon chip.
It's just cool to literally 500 times
colder than the most remote part of outer
space. I mean like a few Milli
Kelvin above absolute zero,
which is really cool too to put
the speed for power in perspective.
Uh, could you please describe a
graph that I've seen you present,
which I believe might start with,
is it 2002 right.
And it looks like it,
it progresses up to the right
almost out of a 45 degree angle.
Now that the angle is, is that important?
I mean it depends on what's on the axes,
but uh,
could you describe what these different,
what these points are points represent?
It's something I have affectionately
called roses law with a sort of homage to
Moore's law. Um, because Moore's law
is actually named by carver mead.
It wasn't Gordon Moore himself who labeled
his law Moore's law and nor did nor
did Jordy rose,
the founder of D-Wave.
But when I was first speaking with him
in 2002 having just read David Deutsch,
his book,
he had produced a single cubit,
they're called cubits for like quantum
bits. So I'll just use the acronym cubit.
He had manufactured one of these untested
and characterized it and had sent to
the manufacturing facility. It was
the cubit, the entire computer.
And think of it as a buy loosen algae,
like a memory array.
It would be like a one bit memory ray.
Got It.
That's a really powerful memory rate.
So when you go from one to two u s you're
now able to explore all possibilities
of two to the second power of, so for
memory states, if you have three cubits,
you could simultaneously explored eight
possible memory states if you have four
16 and so forth. Right? It's a
doubling. So as you add a single cubit,
you've roughly,
even by with some hand waving,
doubled the power of your computer roughly
speaking on the order of a two to the
end phenomenon. So if you were
to add one new cubit every year,
which he just stayed it. So coming
to like where this graph come from,
he just stayed in 2002 I think we're
going to double the number of cubits and a
functional quantum computer
every year in perpetuity.
And so I had to ask is that just because
Gordon Moore said something that sounds
kind of similar and we had a conversation,
I don't remember being particularly
persuaded other than it's a semiconductor
process. It takes roughly a year. Did
that just the prior generation? Yeah,
we should. We should. Why shouldn't we
be able to do this? And sure enough,
that's helpful today. Right? So
that's been 16 years of doublings.
The way the graph gets interesting
though is as with Moore's law,
it comes out of nowhere.
Like, so Moore's law,
you get to actually trace
back hundreds of years,
arguably that our capacity to compute
as a species has been doubling roughly
every year since we started to compute,
since we had any kind of advocates.
I mean like it's kind of weird how this
has been growing and the semiconductor
industry is just the modern version
of that on a quantum computer.
That doubling starts to reach thresholds
where you can do things that you
couldn't do with any computer on earth.
So on this graph he was,
if you look forward and here's where
there's been a little bit of a time delay
by the way, just to full disclosure,
where the power something's computers,
there has been a bit of overhead,
there's been a bit of, you know,
set up and read out times.
There's been a bit of noise and other
things that have made the power of it not,
it's still scales like the original curve,
like that 45 degree angle.
You're painting in people's minds.
But the power that that represents is,
you know,
imagine you have to go like a little,
maybe two or four times bigger
to hit some of these thresholds,
but unless something falls off the rails,
we will soon and like the next couple
of years have computers that can
outperform any computer on earth.
Then you give it another couple of years
and it would outperform all computers
that could ever be built on earth,
even if you use entire matter
of the earth to build them.
And then this is where David Deutsch
started to run this thought process out,
give it another couple of years.
He would outperform all computers that
could possibly be built if you use the
entire matter of the universe as at your
disposal to build in the best possible
computer.
Any human could ever design.
And you gave it the length of the
university and time to work on a problem.
It's still couldn't solve these
problems and the quantum cuter could.
And in due course like
in less than an hour,
like that's when if your head hasn't
already drilled out of your ears,
it just really explodes like pulp and
what there's places where nature gives you
a peak into its wonders, right?
And as a scientist or engineer,
we get these in almost
any field of exploration,
whether it's innerspace of quantum physics
or outer space and the frontiers of
the unknown.
And here's one of those examples that
just opens your eyes to how little we know
in that you'll sometimes see
this may be an experiment. Um,
I give an example of one that David
Deutsch also likes that some people might
remember from your high school
physics. If you have two slits, um,
two very narrow slits and
you shine light through them,
you get this diffraction
pattern on a screen,
on the falling on the
wrong side of the table.
And that's always been
something we learned at the
bulk statistical physics of a
lot of photons, a lot of lights going
and interfering with each other.
It was interference patterns.
Well,
it's fascinating is if you
send single photons at a time,
they will shoot through and if
you just tally up to statistics,
they'll end up creating a distribution
pattern just as if it were many photons
interacting.
So the whole explanation,
the wave theory of light is that
waves interact with each other,
and that's what creates this pattern
is ripple pattern on the other side.
But there's no interaction when you're
single and single photon at a time.
It's not interacting with anything other
than its sister photon in a parallel
universe. Right. And David
Joyce, she was like, well,
that's obviously the explanation that
makes all of this work other than it bends
people's minds. And so the two schools
of thought are, that's the answer,
or I don't want to talk about it.
What is David's background? Is He, oh,
he's a physicist, but yeah. Yeah. Just
to make sure. Yes, absolutely. No,
he knows a lot way more than me
because he's not a charlatan.
Yeah.
How do you even make sense of that?
I mean in terms of considering the
implications because this isn't,
we're not talking about thousands
of years away potentially,
and this is in the
relatively near term future.
What are the implications of that? So the
key to answering that question as well,
what are these computers good for?
Right.
And either good news or bad news depending
on your point of view is they're very
hard to program,
at least historically speaking is a years
would go by between major advances in
the software,
if you will,
the algorithms that one can run on a
quantum computer and do anything useful.
Right.
There was something called
shores algorithm that came
out a few years back that
said, hey, you can
actually factor integers,
meaning break the number
15 into its prime factors.
Three times five is 15 so if I give you
15 tell me what the prime factors are.
You know,
if the number is small,
we can kind of work our way randomly
threw it through either exhaustive search
or some heuristic, but we don't really
have a mathematical way to get the answer.
And the quantum computer now
can just give you the answer,
which it turns out would break
most of cryptography. Um,
any of these mathematically symmetries
are at the core of public key crypto.
So that's kind of worrisome.
Um,
when it's useful for beyond something
that spooks should be interested in is we
literally also in a renaissance
of software discovery.
So things are that it really seems
to be coming to the top of near term
opportunities or quantum chemistry and um,
deep learning or machine learning,
both of which are very interesting.
Quantum chemistry is quite
simply predicting accurately
what a small molecule
will do.
It turns out if you use a normal computer
and you try to solve shortens great
Schrodinger's equations and do like the
what's called the bottoms up ab initio
model, like what does a water
molecule do, what does aspirin do,
how does it behave?
You can't actually model this.
It just computation that grinds to a halt.
A quantum computer could do this
almost on a one to one mapping.
So the quantum computer about the same
complexity as h two o and all of its
electrons is about the size of computer.
You'd need the model it perfectly like
when does it freeze? How this whatever,
what's phase transitions,
all these weird properties of water that
we take for granted that really don't
come from the physics, right?
We learned this in chemistry,
but you don't learn in physics.
And because of the math it's
computationally to complex. Um,
more interesting to me
personally. I mean, by the way,
I first invested in quantum
computing for quantum chemistry.
That was the reason I got excited about
this is what we'd be able to design
drugs more quickly. Figure out, let's give
an example. Let's say you have some new,
uh,
h one n one virus and you're trying to
figure out how can I design a molecule
that would dock to this virus at a
particular place that like if I could only
attach they're chemically, I could
kill it. Well, that's very hard to do.
Very easy to state, very hard to
solve. So you can test a drug,
but you can't have an issue of
just design it out of scratch.
And that's what these hopefully we'll be
able to do soon rapidly accelerate drug
design.
The other area that has enormously wide
applicability is in deep learning and we
can talk more about that field later.
But generally speaking,
building little brains that can learn
something very quickly and like let's say
it's pattern recognition
or image recognition for
any number of applications,
um, and do that much better. So that's
why perhaps it's not surprising.
Google's been the primary customer of
quantum computers for the last 10 years
cause they use deep learning everywhere.
So we're going to, I'm sure get to deep
learning. I shouldn't be so confident.
Well like 75 pages on it comes
back to 75 pages of notes. Sure.
I'll do my best to come
back to deep learning folks.
I'm not yet a deep learner by clearly
with all the notes are neural networks.
That's the same thing basically.
All right, so this is,
you want to come back to that.
Great. All right. So I'll,
I'll put this anonymous
on my mysterious pad here,
but question that is
tangentially related,
but since you mentioned entanglement,
this is something that's become very
interesting to me as a non physicist.
Of course, my ability to dig into
it as is limited, but I heard,
I believe it was radio lab,
I could be making that up,
but an episode of radio lab
where they talked about the,
some of the experimental design and
the results of using lasers to impact,
uh, entangled. Suppose it'd be
Adam's, does that sound right? Uh, or,
um, I'm not sure. There may be. They can
create what's called the booze
Isand Einstein condensate
with lasers in a sense,
trapping light and making it stop
or doing really bizarre things.
So they were looking at entanglement
across, not just distances within a room,
but I didn't know, I think they sent it
on a loop at cern or at 60, 70, 80 miles,
which,
right.
And so I started wondering myself again
as like a professional amateur is not
terribly good at any one thing. It's
was like, well, wait a second. If, if,
if you were to ask David Deutsch,
she might just laugh this
off as a ridiculous question,
but if the Big Bang theory
or if the big bang happened,
as many people imagine it to have happened
or, or think of too to have happened,
is it possible that everything
that we can see, hear, feel,
touch is entangled?
Like is,
is there the possibility that
everything is entangled anyway?
That's a question that I think about,
but I've never asked a physicist.
I'm not sure. Not, not in the,
well my gut is not in the powerful way
that the quantum theory takes advantage
of it, but there is the possibility
of, well first off, let me just,
for those who don't know
the experiment referring to,
they sent two entangled photons down sort
of opposing fiber optic rings and then
when they were far apart from each other,
like miles apart from each other,
they would observe one and notice
that the other resolve that state
instantaneously at the same time.
So in other words that there's this
notion of quantum indeterminacy that you
don't know whether it's a one or a zero
or somewhere routine until you look at
it, the moment you look at
it, it changes the state.
It's this really both strange and and
provocatively provocative notion of the
quantum physics.
And literally if you look at one of them
over let's say on left field, you know,
miles away,
it'll instantaneously resolve the other
one as well as if they were a single
unit.
And in fact you can't have,
like you can't imagine information passing
between them because it's faster than
the speed of light that this is like
it's at the exact same moment that these
things resolve. Oh, I'm coming,
I'm going to get out of
my depth on the takeaway.
I think the main takeaway
that fascinated me,
and maybe the hopefully every listener
is we are just beginning to scratch the
surface of understanding
what these phenomenon are
about and taking advantage of
them in any useful way. Right. So
usually quantum physicists literally for,
you know,
since the beginning of the field have
been more theoretical than experimental,
more a bit more theoretical than
useful. You know, it might you say,
and I think the potential crashing of
this onto business shores is potentially
upon us where, uh, again,
when we talk about it,
let's say the power of deep learning,
if you could build an
artificial intelligence
broadly defined of any kind is
simple one that plays games or a simple
one that recognizes cancer in, you know,
pathology slides or recognizes,
uh, anything in an x ray
in medical imaging sense.
If you can do that better
than anyone else on earth,
that's a business opportunity.
And that capability might start to lend
itself to those who have the cutting
edge of computation.
And in the past,
anyone could buy a computer
and catch up with, you know,
someone who has another computer.
It was a commodity, right? I just,
we'll just go buy some
more computers myself.
But what if the practitioners of
this sort of field are so esoteric,
limited that there's only a handful of
companies that know how to do powerful
computing. That's kind of a
worrisome feature, potentially.
Not to dedicate too much time
to worry some futures, but what,
what do you see as the
most likely existential or
greatest existential risks to
humans, animals, people,
things on this planet? Oh,
I think it'd be very different for humans,
animals and things.
Let's talk about that.
Yeah.
Because I think there's all kinds of
things we can do to hurt ourselves that
nature won't have any problem with.
And all these like March right along the
cockroaches will still be out there, uh,
for many years. Um, since my cockroach
audience is still very small,
we'll go with humans.
They're incredible creatures.
They're going how they're going
to laugh through a lot. So, um,
I worry about the way in
which cultural evolution is,
while it's progressing,
it's not progressing fast enough and
we as a society are going through more
rapid and gut wrenching change of
various sorts that we may or may not be
prepared to handle. So, for example,
we may be in the midst, I would argue,
have a ever accelerating rich poor gap
that politicians and policymakers just
don't have their head around and could
lead to a future of abundance is Peter
Diamandis writes about where everything's
great because physical things are so
inexpensive that even the poorest of the
poor can live like kings of just a few
years prior. Um, but I
think the cultural, um,
in a sense set up for this
is not necessarily right,
which is we don't have a lot of people
thinking about it. Whether it's, you know,
how will,
let's say 10 years from now,
20 years now we provide for
basic human needs globally.
Is it going to be normal
capitalism in a democracy?
Is that going to work just fine for
everyone or will it be some that are
horribly left behind? And I think, um,
social unrest is something that
worries me more and more, I guess in,
in a succinct way.
Um,
there are other things I've been involved
with a nonprofit looking for, you know,
astroid defense.
That's an existential threat of
another kind that's easily addressed.
I mean for you know,
less than $400 million,
you could take that one off the table.
So hopefully that will happen. Um,
pandemic flu or bioterrorism, pause for
a second. So take it off the table by Oh,
so somehow destroying the nose.
It key is just detecting them
long before they hit her.
It's so unlike the movies
Armageddon or deep impact,
you don't want to wait until final
approach to try and do anything about it
seems like a good breaking it apart.
It turns a bolt until shotgun shell like
it's way too late. What you want to do,
and it's actually,
this is what's so interesting is for the
first time ever we can put satellites
up that had these infrared sensors
that can detect these objects at great
distances and track them and
we have enough computational
power to from a couple
of them,
a lot from three observation points,
model out the inbody problem of what
will the next hundred years of this
object's orbit look like and will it hit
earth at any point in the next hundred
years? So that that is a computationally
complex thing we can do today.
So putting up one of those
satellites in a near Venus orbit,
looking out to capture all the threads
to earth we could do today with less
budget than some museums have.
Right.
And the key then is when you see
something that will hit earth,
let's say 50 years from now or 30
years from now, you just bump it.
All you have to do is like give it the
slightest little Delta v today and all of
its orbits around the Sun. By the time
it eventually intersects with earth,
it's in a totally different place
and we can computationally no,
yeah he was rear ended by a tiny bit or
hit it head on by a tiny bit and then
you're done. Right. Problem solved. Wow.
But you need time on your side that
it takes years for that tiny nudge to
accumulate enough distance delta that
you miss something as big as earth.
So interrupted.
I think your segue to bioterrorism,
bioterrorism worried me a lot post nine
11 cause I realized looking into it and
from investments I'd made
that it's increasingly
becoming the case that a small
number of people in fact individual with
let's say a college education in this
field could build weapons of mass
destruction. It used to take armies,
it used to take,
you know,
despots and fascist leaders of countries
and resources of countries to wield a
weapon of mass destruction to build
going to the CRISPR gene editing,
things like that. Yeah, exactly. So, you
know, synthesizing smallpox, you know,
weaponizing it, doing something like
in injecting the interleukin four gene,
which makes it incredibly deadly in,
in mouse pox.
Pox viruses affect all organisms that
get to a certain concentration level and
the planet. So aunts, dear,
anything that live in dense areas,
chickenpox develop a unique
pox virus for that thing.
It's kind of nature's way of telling you
there's way too many of you people on
this planet than the um,
they can be bio engineered like crazy.
And this worried me because when I
spoke to people in various government
agencies who spend their time modeling
and doing red team simulations of
bioterrorism outbreaks, there
only answer at the time was, well,
we hope they wouldn't do this.
I just kind of like a leap of faith that
this is such a horrible thing to wield
that that people would stop short.
And at the time I,
they gave me no comfort
and as time passes,
I'm actually think there is
an element of truth to that.
That's not the kind of thing that typical
terrorist cell can get someone fired
up about it. There is a weird
thing, even within the worst,
if whatever we put in quote marks, worst
parts of societal, uh, troublemakers,
if you will, on the planet where this
isn't a place they tend to go, right?
Flying a plane in a building is more
natural vector of getting attention for
your mission and getting someone to
volunteer for the duty than saying, oh,
I'm going to go kill a bunch of
innocent people. You know, with,
with a contagious agent, it's kind
of weird cross product of a threat.
How did you convince yourself of that?
Why am I worried about it too? Okay. Yeah.
It's on my top three list of worries.
Yeah. What are the others? Um, let's see.
Let's see. The inequality slash
unrest. Um, bioterrorism. Oh shoot.
What is my other one? Uh,
well, climate change of course.
Oh my God. Climate Change.
She said the thing about climate change
that worries me is the things I didn't
know.
I'll give one example.
Last week I learned of a new thing that
I really didn't learn to worry about
until last week,
which is of all places out of NASA ames,
the former director was telling me they'd
been doing these interesting studies
trying to figure out how can we
induce hibernation and mammals,
which for interstellar travel
would be great. You know,
then the movies, the human,
somehow I'll go into hibernation mode,
right?
And then all in all the movies we see,
and then we're doing studies with rats
and they could actually get rats to
hibernate for two days at a time by
exposing to the hydrogen sulfide.
And that immediately led me to ask,
well, wait, why is that adaptive? I owed,
we have this sort of latent pathway that
really doesn't seem useful for anything
that puts rats to sleep for two days
at a time and they would die if it was
longer than that and it turned out back.
One of the major extinction events,
and I'll try to be more concise
here than I might otherwise be.
If there was a major volcanic,
we have plenty of numbers.
It led to major climate change and the
polar ice caps melted a greenhouse gas
greenhouse effect in the
palm of the ice caps melting.
Wasn't that sea level levels Rose
Rose that just affects Bangladesh,
Miami and Yup, but it doesn't take
out humanity if sea levels rise,
the thing that could take out humanity
is it's the ocean current start,
stop going and part of that was driven
by a freshwater or melt off the pulse.
So potentially long before the polls are
completely gone or perhaps completely
unrelated, the temperature change.
If the ocean stops circulating,
you get this complete dead zones
where there's organisms depend on the
circulation of nutrients to survive and
basically purple and brown bacteria took
over and they are these
hydrogen sulfide is,
you'd have these waves usually coupled
up to two days at a time of just
literally lethal gasses sweeping across
the landscape that the survivors learn
how to hibernate through.
It's an a long winded way.
The thing that both was both interesting,
like maybe here's a hint of how we can
induce hibernation and mammals like
humans,
but also a reminder that we've had
climate change many times in this planet.
And really bad things can happen that
have nothing to do with carbon or methane
or all the things we're focused on.
Uh,
it could be the hydrogen
sulfide gas that kills us,
which is the rotten smell of eggs. You
know, you'll, you'll see, you know,
it's nasty stuff
on the social and recipes and just
because I know there are many people out
listening who will be wondering this,
what do you see as the preventative steps,
if any, that can be taken
to mitigate that risk? Yeah.
So first I was looking at it like, well,
does it feel like it's self correcting?
Is it self rectifying?
Is there something that's a
natural governing feedback loop,
a negative feedback loop that
says, well, the rich get richer.
Is there something that naturally
makes that not continue further?
And unfortunately there's a lot of
positive feedback loops, not in the, uh,
not in the sort of normative sense,
but in just a regulatory sense of it
just there's a runaway thing, right?
Like runaway climate change and
that is you can get, um, well,
first off in is every business becomes
an information business over time.
Like when, what I mean by that
is if the basis of competition,
why is company a winning over company B?
Is it the way they process information?
Is it a software layer to their business
that I think is rippling through every
part of industry, whether
it's the aerospace industry,
the automotive industry,
agriculture, right? It's
not, oh, he worked harder. He
was an artisan in his field.
That's why he's a better farmer. Or
She, it's, oh no, he's got better genes,
scripts from Monsanto or whoever.
And the basis of competition.
Agriculture's moved to information
tech as every industry goes that way,
those industries will start to look
more like where do you see Google and
Facebook a winner take all kind of
dynamic where eat between firms,
you have very few winners and within
firms you have very few winners,
so at every fractal scale it's
kind of like a winner take all.
There's a few people within these firms
that Garner most of the wealth and
there's few companies that Garner
most of the wealth in each industry.
Now that's perhaps so that trend is
somewhat negative in that technology takes
over more and more. It didn't
innovates more and more of the economy.
It subsumes or eats the world, if you
will, that I think it'll be a side effect.
One other side effect that's negative is
people sometimes reject maternity when
they can't keep up. Like you sometimes
subscribe to a different belief system,
not science and math is the progress
of vector of humanity. It's like,
I'm going to reject science,
I'm going to reject math.
And there's entire countries
that are taking this stance,
which is scary because
they'll fall farther,
farther behind perhaps with an inability
to catch up to maternity when and if
they choose to. So that worries
me. The only current quote,
negative feedback loop thing that prevents
welcoming from completely crazy is
that luckily, and I think
maybe understandably, um,
the wealthiest tech entrepreneurs tend
not to live like rock stars and you know,
are rap stars in, in La. They tend to
give back in a simple explanation for me,
having seen many of these people before
they made billions of dollars and after
is that if you've made goings at
dollars and let's say under five years,
you don't tend to ascribe that to
your incredible hard work and superior
intelligence, right? It is a farce, right?
To hold onto the belief that
I am better than others.
That's why I'm a billionaire.
And so they give back like in droves.
I like incredible acts of philanthropy.
And so right now the philanthropy, um,
governor is the one thing I see that's
at least a positive that says, well,
maybe this actually will allow people
like gates and others to take on multi
year quests,
like eradicating malaria or polio,
now polio and next malaria in a way that
governments can't even take on, right?
You have projects that exceed
the budget of the GDP of nations.
the lifespan of any politician.
And luckily this is what these people
are choosing to do rather than just show
off. Right? Uh, and so I'm
really happy about that. Um,
and I'm trying to live
my life that way as well.
So the question of going
forward is there's a lot of
debates about basic income,
universal basic income and experiments
that are trying to get funded to see if
it works the way people think it might.
Um,
I think there could be all
kinds of experiments in
almost corporate health plans
writ large. So right now most companies
in the more than a thousand employees,
we'll manage the health
plan of care in place.
It's cheaper than going to a third party,
like I will actually pay
for your healthcare because
let me paying some third
party,
you know,
they're just making money off that and
I've got enough critical mass with a
thousand employees. Does that make
sense? Well, imagine food, shelter,
clothing and healthcare
are all equally cheap.
Meaning everything costs a dollar a pound
in the world. That's a physical thing.
That's,
that's where we're heading in the end
point was all physical things should be
the same cost bag of potatoes,
dollar, pound, bag of chips,
dollar pound. Why Heart?
Because, um, and, and then what
you'll pay for is the software,
the intellectual property,
the thing that that in certain
places could lock up the mail.
Maybe that Ferrari costs more because
it's the design, not the materials,
but it's just manufacturing
methods are all converging.
Whether you think of it as additive
manufacturing or just traditional
manufacturing,
that stuff is not the rare commodity
you pay for intellectual content like
entertainment and software.
It's like that's what all feature Connie's
will based on in physical stuff's all
at the same. What are the
means of manufacturer? Well,
we're going to grow things.
I think increasingly in the future
I think we're going to grow, uh,
with algae and other things, chemicals
like so we think much sheer, you know,
metric tons of stuff,
you know,
liquid chemicals is a big
part of it and we get all,
almost all that 90 plus percent from
oil today and the petrochemical economy,
it's all going to shift to renewables.
And so that sort of manufacturing stuff
like the stuff that goes into plastics,
which is more and more of the
physical world that we're in. Um,
obviously metals will still come from,
you know, no, unfortunately metal sources,
but,
um,
I think we'll shift to carbon and other
kinds of materials increasingly for
structural stuff. Um, this
is potentially in the,
the nanotech slash carbon economy
of the future that, you know,
building things out of carbon nanotube
like structures and meshes is just a much
lighter materials,
uh,
sort of effective and efficient way of
doing things. So we can look to nature.
And how does a spider silk
thread outperform on almost
any other modern material
and like white, there are startups
that are building synthetic silk.
Now with these old nano machines
that reproduce the, what the spinner,
it doesn't a spider so across it,
but just coming back to just
this inequality point, uh, in,
in the corporate path potentially there.
Um,
or it could be like a peace
corps equivalent that says
if you work for x number
of years, you get healthcare in
theory for a longer period of time.
Right?
In,
why couldn't that start to subsume the
way some companies already provide lunch
for free? Why couldn't in a sense, basic
food, shelter, clothing and healthcare,
the provided for free
and the health care part,
by the way right now is a huge part of
the economy. But it shouldn't be right?
I think we're also, and this is
something I want to invest in, um,
we're going to find a way to make the
information search of health free so we
don't have to pay for the diagnosis.
And I can't imagine a future where
knowing what I need to do to make myself
healthy, it would be something
I'd pay for it. The actual doing,
if it involves surgery,
maybe the pills,
they should all be in dollar a pound
and the physical thing and that future.
I think we'll be incredibly enabling
for changing society to a stable and we
don't fear for the health of your
children or their ability to live.
Then you could have almost
like a renaissance where
you pursue the things that
are meaningful to you, whether it's
poetry or science or what have you.
Meaningful work online.
People do this all the time.
We spend a ridiculous amount of our
time on things that aren't paid right,
but are meaningful to us.
And that I think increasingly is what
the world will look like in the future.
And meaningful work and contributions,
not a job in the traditional sense.
If the pills are dollar pound is the,
how do you maintain the ability to
develop and innovate those drugs?
Is it just because the computational
power become so inexpensive that you have
then, uh, competitors to the
current incumbents who of course,
hi incentivize to protect. Exactly.
It's the long run has because you, you,
you can imagine any,
any current phase or even long term,
whether you call it transition phase or
just this is how the new ones come to
market as you have to reward of course,
that effort in to the extent that effort
is still as expensive as it is today,
you would, you need to recoup it. Right?
And that would be in the hills real
property questions, sort of the,
it's almost again, like
the software of it. The,
the generic manufacturers know
how to make the drug. It's,
but for law around intellectual
property that it costs more.
So the physical manufacturing is
still gonna be a dollar found.
And now the question is, is it priced
as such? And so in my model of, of this,
you'd start with the generics and um, and
have this massive distribution channel.
Like, if you want to reach
a billion people, you know,
you can sign on to this platform for the,
you know,
the poorest of the poor
and reach a billion people,
had some sort of reasonable
costs position for a generic.
But I think the cost of discovery will
also come down back to the computation
and the one quantum chemistry side so
that it doesn't need to take so long and
be so expensive.
And right now you have an FDA regulatory
system that's a bit archaic in that
regard where they aren't quite set up
yet and they're trying to transition,
but they're slow at this into a world
where you have personalized medicine in a
world where my medicine is different than
yours and therefore the clinical trial
concept really changes. Right.
So we've been talking mostly, uh,
current,
Rsa Present and future tense.
I want to go back to that two and a half
years. Oh, sure. Undergrad. How does,
how does such a thing happen?
Well, I mean, how's that
possible? It's interesting.
I took it as a challenge
when I started at college.
I was going to Stanford and I realized
it was expensive and my folks are
immigrants from Estonia and I kind of
found it difficult and we were middle
class people at the time.
So I didn't get financial aid and I was
looking at this, I'm like, you know,
this costs a lot.
I just felt guilt.
So I looked at the various
rules for graduation and it
felt like a simple system
of equations like this plus
that equal to this was like,
I actually boil it down to,
oh I see.
They're just trying to get four
years of tuition Nadia, so what,
where can I explore the corner cases?
And so I came in with the
maximum number AP credits.
So it actually goes back to my
high school saint Mark's in Dallas.
That incredibly well
prepared me for college.
So I took the maximum number
of AP units that I could.
But of course universities limit, not
surprisingly, how much of that applies.
I also took a couple of summer classes
that I could transfer in from another
school. They'd have a certain number
you could do. I Max that out one summer.
While I was doing summer jobs at hps,
it took a night classes.
But most of all I got learned
a trick from the Grad students.
This is the key answer actually. Um, by
the time you get to be a Grad student,
you realize that you're limited to
something like nine units a quarter.
And that's kind of limiting the, if you
take five minute classes, well shoot,
you know,
you're taking class in half.
So what they realized is you can sign
up for a class for less units than it's
listed, just not more. So the check
sum on the computer algorithm was not,
did you say it's a five unit class and
it's or say at six and it's the only five.
It's you know,
is it that or or less.
So you can just say it's a even a zero
unit class or one you use and make it
whatever you want. So you aren't
taking more than 20 minutes a quarter.
So you meet that algorithm yet you've
got all the prerequisite classes you
needed for the next one. He had to look,
you have to map this out early on, right?
You have to start freshman
year to make this work. Oh.
And I had to get a physics teacher to
let me take a class and a teacher sort of
against the prerequisites and
look, I really can do this. Let me,
let me try to take your class a year
earlier than I should so that I could get
the prereq chain going.
So there's all these simultaneous
equations you have to solve.
But the signing up for
more classes with the key,
there was like one winter quarter when I
took the Quillon of eight classes where
you'd normally take a load of four, um,
that made that possible. So when did it,
if it did,
when did the budgeting stop
being a concern because you
then went on to continue
your schooling, right? It'll
flip completely total mode shift.
When I started my master's program and I
became a research assistant and cause I
paid for school. Uh, so
the moms that HP at HP,
I started a master's in which engineering?
Right?
So it's Phil at Stanford and I see that
was a research assistant professor,
Hennessy,
who went,
who went on to do amazing things there
and was an entrepreneur himself. Um,
at one point. And, uh, and I shifted
gears. I didn't want to leave school.
I mean like going through two and
half years. The problem is like, wow,
I kind of missed out on a lot of
the social life and like living. Um,
and so I basically at that point stretched
down and try to stay as long as I
could. Got a balloon payment. It's
Kinda funny how incentives change. Yeah.
Now I want to stay, I
don't want to leave. Right.
And I found a way to be in the
freshman dorms as a Grad student,
which is awesome as a
computer coordinator there,
which meant I kept the computers running
and kept the paper in the printers.
But man,
I could have sort of freshman dorm
life all over again as a Grad student.
And that was fun.
Uh,
so if we look then at your masters,
and I suppose it would have been,
maybe it was simultaneous,
but if or after you could tell us the
NBA since all that came later that came
later.
So the NBA,
why did you decide to get an Mba
and if would you do it again?
If,
why or why not?
A lot of folks who I knew and know or
asking that same question and I think,
uh, it's, I think it's a challenge a
lot of higher ed is facing, which is,
is this a vocational thing? Is this mean
one unusual thing about business school,
it's the only educational program I know
of where everyone comes in with prior
work experience, you know, even law
school and Med school and what have you,
you know, you're just going
straight in from undergrad.
And so it's got a very different
kind of feel to it that way.
And then people might ask,
especially when there's something
like a.com boom going on in the 90s.
Do I want to step out for a couple of
years from the economy and miss maybe that
window,
that opportunity that might be so ripe.
So the main reason I went is a
networking really to uh, expand the,
uh, the sort of an end to
learn frankly, um, two x,
but the networking came first to mind to
meet a bunch of people who've come from
all kinds of different backgrounds
that I could learn from, uh,
not only at school but throughout my life.
And one of the sub points on that is,
for example, pretty basic questions
like, what do I want to do in my life?
I had bounced around from engineering to
management consulting prior to business
school and thought, well,
from what I know today,
I'd maybe want to go to product marketing.
I thought that's what I wanted to do.
I don't know. I don't know anyone
that's done that. They know. And, well,
if I've got a business goal in
winter where I want to look,
there's going to be plenty of students
who've done that in the past and they're
looking to do something new.
And so you get all the,
of all the consultants generally to
consulting, you know, all the, you know,
I bankers trying to leave I banking
and learn about something new. Um,
what better place.
And then especially with your employer
hoping to leave his bang for it. Exactly.
That's exactly right. In fact,
that's exactly what happened to me.
I was financed by my former employer,
so I had that sort of safety net.
And then when I decided not to go back,
I had to pay for all my
tuition in one on one check.
That was don't let that one go that
you have a, it's a loan. And I mean,
rightly so. I didn't expect to get a
free ride and not go back. But, um,
but it did raise a barrier to leaving. Um,
oh, the other thing is learning. I mean,
I should, it should go. I
mean the business was not
what I went to learn per se.
I knew there'd be some classes about
business that I thought would be helpful,
but I'd done so much at Bain that I kind
of had a small business degree already.
And I taken the classes back when I was
an Undergrad and a Grad student prior in
accounting and finance. So I'd
already taken a lot of, again,
the core courses I placed out of every
core course at business school too. And,
and went right into the sort
of the electives and the
more interesting classes.
But I also knew that it was an opportunity
to take classes in other departments,
you know, to brush up on actually the
molecular stimulation of all things.
And one of the classes I took
was on modeling, you know,
quantum mechanical
properties of materials.
Like you normally don't get to
take a class like that. Um, and,
and that really all played out. So it
gave me, so did it do what I expected?
In a way it did. I didn't know a venture
capital existed when I grew up in Texas.
I'd heard the term,
I never met a venture capitalist.
Never knew anything about them. Didn't,
wouldn't know how to reach one. No idea.
Right now man,
I grew up there wasn't internet,
so like they literally would
not know how to reach one.
They're not in the phone book and you
know, there's no way to find them. Um,
they really aren't putting up billboards
or advertising in any way. So, um,
the entire transition,
the venture occurred because of people
I met there and got a good location for
it too. That's true in the middle of
Silicon Valley. That's true. Yeah.
And that was the only school I applied
to by the way. You think about it.
Do you want to go visit school?
I did not apply to any other
school because there was
another school that would
have met that goal.
Right, right. So, uh, uh,
and also I learned a lot and the
network back to the network, uh,
almost every investment I made,
I think it was almost for the first
year or two out of business goal.
And that was a lot because
it's middle of the.com boom.
For me had some business will connection.
It was either literally entrepreneurs
were from business school or it was sent
to me by a professor from that business
school or like do like for the first
year. That's how I jump started.
Everything I did and I don't know. So
my madness slash method is usually,
uh,
not chronological sewer charge. Uh,
we're going to zoom out a little bit.
What mistakes do you see otherwise?
Very smart venture capitalists making?
Are there any patterns?
Are there any particular
types of mistakes? Could be
investors broadly speaking,
but yeah. Oh my God, tons all over
the place. And to be fair, uh,
I'll try to drop in and mention
when I made those same mistakes.
So I by no means I'm trying to
judge as if I know better. Um,
but two that jump to mind.
One is way too many seem to be a of
loss avoidance or fearful and I'll come,
I'll elaborate that in a moment.
And then,
but the other one that jumps
to mind equally is, um,
they think that they've hit upon
the only formula for success. And,
yeah, that has many different levels
at which that's worry something.
So the first one, um, this
notion that of being fear driven,
I've come across so many investors
who will say something like, well,
we have a strategy to try not to try not
to lose any company as if that's like
we're in the trenches. You know,
every company will succeed.
And if you've just been at
this game for a few decades,
you'll realize that's just
folly, right? The earlier ego,
the higher your death rate's going to
be a startup, the majority will fail.
Just give them time. And that's sad.
Reality took awhile to sink in for some,
but until it does, you're going to
be very timid in your investing.
So most investors I see just let all of
the biggest home runs passed them by,
uh, almost every term sheet I've written
to a company that's turned out to be a
spectacular home run. I had no
competition at the time of the series.
It was kidding. Like nobody else
would invest in the company.
What would the reasons for not
investing? Oh yeah, it's crazy. Uh,
it's way too early. It's a science
project, no traction home. Yeah,
there's no product. I mean, so, um, so
first off, I almost everything I'm doing,
there's no product, no customers
yet. It's an idea. It's in prototype,
stage of development or there's no even
prototype yet or they just don't agree
the world is going to change in this
way. So, uh, and in often cases,
conventional wisdom would
support their point of view.
Like let's not invest in any automotive
company because every investment,
since Henry Ford has filled like 100%
of them that are just roadkill scattered
on the highway and there's been,
but it's, by the way, many,
many startups funded well over $10
million, you know, so it was like back,
you know, decades ago. That's a lot
of money. And the automotive sector,
all of which have failed, um, many and
batteries, many and solar, I mean just,
just scores. I mean maybe hundreds of
companies that failed. So when you've,
let's say lost four times in a row,
you just give up on the category.
So sometimes it's the more
experience grizzled investors like,
well that whole sector,
I'm just going to like steer clear of
it because I'm too many scar tissues
neither. Um, but that's not
really the thing I'm talking
to think about, you know,
new entrance to the venture business
people who you would think would take a
strategy of differentiating myself from
my peers and a bait like having a basic
strategy.
Let's say they say,
why would an entrepreneur want to work
with me versus all the other firms?
And if it's like, well, I'm investing
in the hot sector, pick whatever it is,
dishwasher, you know, consumer
internet or social this or you know,
blockchain that it's like, well
it's the hot thing. Well, yeah,
but this is also a hundred other people
who had the exact same idea you just did.
It's the hot things. Like
why are you different? And
there's like no answer. Right?
So, um, this, this lack of
strategic thinking about a,
and also lack of thinking of,
of, of, of a longterm
strategy. Like, okay, whatever
you're doing today was that,
is that going to work 10 years from now?
Whatever that strategy is and like I don't
hear strategy from anyone. Like okay,
here's how I'm going to stand out
over a sustained period of time.
Here's how I will, um, you know, either,
and it can be simple things like
I'll have a niche, I'll only do x, Y,
Z and there'll be known for
my niche or my specialty.
What worked for you in the early days
when you're just getting started?
It was um,
well first it was a stroke of great luck,
which is the.com boom as we now call it,
you know,
was just starting to happen and was
ready for that and open minded enough.
So I didn't have the scar tissue,
which is by the way,
scar tissue for traditional investors
was if you invest in anything,
it was like entertainment or media or
shrink wrap software as they called it,
which is low price software for consumers.
That would be the
consumer software segment.
But it was just a horrible place
and games hits driven business.
It still is a horrible segment is to
do non Internet consumer price points
stuff.
I just said that zone.
So they thought the Internet was that
they didn't realize it's an entirely
different business model. The whole
what we now know around cloud computing,
around subscription services, around
viral marketing, its potential.
None of this was known at the beginning.
And if you put it into a prior bucket,
it would be all those are bad sectors.
So unbelievably one of the
biggest investment opportunities
probably the venture
industry has ever seen was a largely
avoided by most venture capital firms.
And when I started in 1995 we did
about a third of all internet investing
industry wide. Wow. Like
the entire venture industry.
And that quickly changed in
[inaudible] 86 87 and excuse me,
96 [inaudible] 97 and when
Netscape at its IPO, boom,
everything changed because now
there was know example of a winter,
this pattern will come again and
space investing in everything.
Like as soon as you have a single winner,
then the sheep phenomenon in the
herd mentality kicks in, right?
So you have scores of people and then
investing in the sector after he's had his
first one. So to your question, um,
being under the tutelage
of Tim draper to say, Hey,
actually let's try to think big.
I mean I credit him for being my
mentor into the industry to say not,
let's think about it the way bankers do.
Let's not be fearful.
Let's ask the entrepreneur how they're
underestimating the market size to think
how much bigger might this opportunity be.
Then even the people pitching it or
imagining that's a thought experiment I
often like to go through and there'll
be times when the occasional,
not often where I'll be like, wow, you
are so underselling your opportunity.
Cause normally I,
I'm just trying to sell to the maximum
extent possible to predict the largest
possible addressable market to think,
well phase one of my business, I do this.
Then phase two I take over
the world in some way, right?
And then to actually try to push them
further and then want to invest in them,
you know,
is an interesting adjunct because then
they know you're on the same page. So I,
so I credit Tim draper, I could at the
Internet. And then most importantly, um,
is there's a,
there was a simple rule.
I started implementing it and I
don't remember when it started.
It just seemed like the natural thing
to do, um, around early stage investing.
So when I thought about this, I was
like, okay, most things fail. If they,
when they've got to be huge, okay,
check. They should change the world.
They should be disruptive. You know,
those are words people use. Well,
how would I know if something really is
big and disruptive? Like, Oh, everyone,
everyone entrepreneur claims it,
right?
Like he'd be doing a payment processing
thing for backend, whatever, you know,
payroll systems. Like we're going to
change the world of payroll. Right. Okay.
What really is going to make
an enormous opportunity is,
it seemed to me that a, they're
describing an enormous market, but B,
here's the killer.
No one else has done it before.
Like instill the simple rule I've used
throughout my entire career investing is
I wanna invest in things that are
unlike anything I've seen before.
And there's all kinds of correlates to
come out of that. The first is, yeah,
you're investing in some unusual things
like d wave, you know, back in 2002,
there were no other quantum computer
startups, zero on the planet earth.
There was not a single company
claiming to build a quantum computer,
big or small actually for about
five years afterwards as well.
So that one is like the most extreme
like well maybe for good reasons.
No one was doing it back
then when hotmail first came.
There's nothing like it that we'd
seen when I first invested in Skype.
There was anything quite
like that. The, the,
the way they did peer to peer voiceover
Ip. Um, as similarly with Tesla,
an electric vehicles.
And I can get it to why that one maybe
is the most corner case of we'll wait.
There are a lot of electric car startups.
Why is that one specialty?
And we can talk about it, but
certainly space x, you know,
who would qualify as well as unique
ideas at the time in the startup domain.
And,
but the benefit for my career was it has
me perpetually searching for the next
great technology wave.
So just when the.com boom was
getting to it's fevered pitch,
I wasn't smart enough.
I know that this is a kid.
I wasn't not smart enough
to predict a crash.
I know that it wasn't
cause I was contributing in
writings and other things at
that time saying well it's a boom is just
starting, it's going to go up, up, up, up.
Right. I believe that because
I just want to do that.
It's going to keep going and then we
wouldn't have like a correction. Um,
but on the other hand,
I was not finding anything unique.
I sought for business plans for
selling pantyhose on the web.
Like all we're going to do cause l.com
that venture back like, like three others.
Like really like for business plans to
sell pantyhose or just balls.com and like,
Oh God, what is just balls
do? Oh yeah, just balls.
Venture backed just sells false. The name
was awesome. We got just false. Come.
What do we sell balls? You want to bat?
No. You want a glove? No, we got balls,
balls and all kinds of small balls.
Big Balls, golf balls, tennis balls.
Wait a second, where were you? A
founder? No. Okay. Just making sure.
But this shows you how
absurd it got to say.
Take the economy and like the
Internet changes everything.
We're going to like divide up the economy
in weird ways that hasn't been divided
up before and make that a business.
Like that's when I knew this is crazy and
I started investing in nanotechnology.
I total left field shift.
Um,
and there's a reason I picked
that particular sector.
But the important point is I didn't
keep investing in the Internet companies
long past their prime. Not because I was
smart on when the correction would come,
but because they weren't unique anymore.
There's like every viral marketing idea
that I at the time that I could find had
come now to my, so I avoided
a lot of pain. We love,
we like if you add up every internet,
remember we did so many of them.
If you had every internet company
we invested in that lost money,
add them all up.
It was less than single deals,
lost from other firms like [inaudible]
dot com lost more money than everything
we've ever done combined because
we didn't load up the boat,
sort of drink our own koolaid too
deep in any one of them. And we were,
every one of them was unique so
there wasn't like this sector risk.
So you get diversification for frequent,
I definition your diversified portfolio
and it had any movement and has been
throughout my career always on
lookout to learn something new,
knowing that I'm going to
have to hop to new sector,
not saying going to spend my whole life
as a semi conductor investor or as a
consumer software investor because
that is so limiting. Yeah. Right.
That might have a good 10 year run,
but if you're not continually learning
something new at the edge is pivoting
from the edges of what you already know,
just something slightly different.
You're going to be constantly,
why did you choose now the technology
that was a bit of a mistake, but um,
it was a mistake in retrospect.
Um,
but it's the only thing I felt I
differentially knew better than others.
It was hearkening back to which,
which,
which fortunately it wasn't that many
years prior that I had been studying some
really hard technologies like molecular
modeling and you know, chip design.
It did some chip design
it at Hewlett Packard.
So I had enough as I looked at the venture
landscape differential knowledge air
to say,
well,
there's something I could Harken back
to that's not the internet because the
Internet anyone could do at this point.
Right.
And the angel investors to flooding
in like, you know, every banker,
consultants flooding is like the
landscape littered with capital and people
investing in that sector.
Well, there's nothing, we're
not in nanotech. I had been,
uh,
exploring at the foresight institute a
number of other sort of think tank like
conferences that the radical potential
has had to revolutionize a bunch of
things.
And the one part that I think was
indicative of what's to come later in my
career, it was not really an end in
any way an industry. It isn't a sector,
it doesn't describe a company.
There's no such thing as a nanotech
company unless you're building tools to
service that industry. You know in a weird
way, manufacturing equipment maybe now,
but not any attractive sectors.
It more was a set of science
and technology capabilities
that would strap across
many industries,
so even today there'll be companies
that will meet with and things that were
unique in that from that era will play
out like well the value of simulation on
any molecular system. Like, well
how, how good is your simulation?
I need physical thing.
You're building in general these questions
or process questions like like how do
you do innovation? How do you do
entrepreneurship? That carries through,
but that platform technology, which,
let me just tell you what I'm,
what I mean by this. Nano tech was
like a platform applied to men or ears,
new ways of doing material
science if you will.
Then there's this whole
field of synthetic biology,
like if you can manipulate DNA
with CRISPR or other technologies,
what are all the things you could do
with that capability and it's very broad.
It's not just health and food and then
more recently deep learning neural
networks,
what we might describe as narrow AI.
That whole field is widely applicable.
I think every company will
use it eventually. So again,
we can come to that later.
But that's like a platform that's not
they other shirt today there was some
quote machine learning companies,
all they do is stuff
related to machine learning.
But much more interesting is all of the
industries that will be changed by the
use of machine learning, the
vertical industries. Um, and so
yeah, to put it, to put a cap on it and
nanotech you know, if you look, think,
look back at it today,
well no there isn't any now tech industry,
it'd be like saying, well
where's the thermodynamics
industry? Well Shit, you know,
version one right bit the sort of is like
thermodynamics as a concept. You know,
there was a time when actually companies
named themselves thermo electron and
you know,
through medics there were all these ones
that it's just now subsumed into the
fabric of science and engineering. So
as a geek, I've always been fascinated.
Are there see changes in basically
how we do science and engineering?
Maybe that's the simplest
way of saying it.
And I think today deep learning is
the best example that a fundamentally
different way of doing engineering.
So that one more time. The loss of,
of fundamental.
So I think deep learning,
or let me just call it machine learning
cause there's a bunch of sub branches.
This is everything from generative design
in, in, in, in sort of the autodesk cad,
Cam Sands. It's, you know, it's,
it's studying seller Tom. By the way.
Steve Wolff from does its genetic
proteins sell automata. Ah,
these are simple little,
a simple little,
a mathematical construct that just says
if you're going to draw, oh my God,
you're probably to edit this out
of the final thing cause it's the,
it may not relate to anything
other than it created this book,
a new kind of science and it really a
series of epiphany's for Wolfrem and
others that,
that the world is really interesting
when you look at iterative algorithms and
applied millions and billions at times.
So seller trauma is just imagine you
start with a random dot or two and then x
line automaton. But with,
yeah, it's sort of unveil.
So you have this little simple rule,
almost like a turning machine that says,
I'm just going to go left to right
and look at the dots above me.
And if the dot above me,
I'll look at the three dots about me,
one directly above me left and to the
right and based on all possibilities of
those three dots, which is, you know, to
the third power, um, uh, possibilities.
I'll have either a daughter,
not a.here.
And so you would think that such
a simple rule that just says,
look at the three dots into,
and there's literally only
16 possible things that I'm
going to, you know, uh, uh,
conditions that I could be seeing up
there. Um, I'll have some other, you know,
I'll do some something.
In most cases it's very boring.
It's just like the whole thing is
black or it's got like a nice pattern
triangles. But in a few
cases, like real 31,
it unpacks into this incredible
complexity that is not repeating.
And there's no way to jump to, let's
say the fourth, the fifth or the 50th,
their hundredth Le Layer of this
unfolding. You have to run the experiment.
And the reason I find
this so philosophically
interesting is this is the same
thing in evolution. It's the same thing
in neural networks. It's the same thing.
And all these new engineering modalities
where you can't mathematically get a
shortcut to the answer, you actually have
to just run this little algorithm over.
No, no, no her again. So you can't, like
for example, you can't reverse evolve.
You can't figure out where did we come
from in any direct way. It's sort of lost.
You can run the tape forward,
but you can't run it backwards.
You can't do mathematical
shortcut across it.
And so an example of why this is as
a thought experiment is important is
whenever you're developing these
neural networks, when you're,
whenever you're training,
let's say these little ais,
and I think this is the
path to AI in general.
So it's important that
this is how it works.
You can't understand
the thing you've made,
nor can you predict as you train the
further and further what you're going to
get. There's a bit of discovery
emergence, if you will.
It's kind of like raising a teenager or
parenting more than it is programming
that you can learn about
the process of creation.
Like I know how to make a teenager,
but I can't tell you exactly
how it all works. Right.
And I certainly can't go in there after
I'm done and tweak a few neurons to make
him smarter or French speaking
or whatever. It's like, no,
that's a really weird artifact
that works really powerfully.
But it's not purposeful design.
It doesn't do what I tell it to do.
Exactly. It can learn to do what
I trained it to do. But you know,
with some edge cases it's a little out
of control and that's what I think the
AI's of the future will look like.
So I,
I can come back to it if you want to talk
about AI and deep learning, but I just,
you asked about seller Tamida
and the process learning.
The key with this question started
with his engineering, right? Yep.
So they wanted,
that I wanted to say is I think deep
learning slash machine intelligence is the
biggest advance in how
we can do engineering.
Specifically engineering since
the scientific method itself.
So can you weigh that gland engineering,
I've been random like I think
astrologists jewel, I think this is true.
And then you have the scientific method.
You leased a method of
compounding knowledge over time.
This is a different way of innocence,
growing solutions to problems
instead of purposely designing them.
But you can build things that
exceed human understanding.
We're doing this all over the
place in molecular engineering,
in software design and
in a variety of fields.
We have sort of reached the limit
in many cases of what a human,
any human or even group of humans can
put their heads together and design and
now we can push way past that and build
things beyond our own understanding,
which is pretty powerful. Yeah.
Could you define, uh, just revisit,
you might have already done it indirectly,
but the deep learning and neural networks.
Yeah,
I guess I have sort of an
approximate equal sign here.
I'm not sure if like they're
synonymous in the 80s.
They call it neural
networks and deep learning.
There is a reason the word deep Cayman.
Well first you want a new name when
something kind of came and went and let's
pass a,
you know,
a couple of decades ago because I studied
neural networks second eighties. Um,
you know,
I think of it a new moniker,
but there is a reason deepen
the sense of more layer.
So what do they have in common?
And in fact in general that works I
think is could be a more generic term for
all this.
It's inspired by the brain.
It's a way of simulating
a brain like subsets.
So not the whole brain.
But imagine if you were to take a
little tiny chunk of your brain,
the cortical column or some area and
say, well, what's really going on? Well,
you have cells that connect to
a bunch of others in our brain.
It's usually a fan out of a thousand or
so to 10,000 connections from each one.
So huge fan out.
Each cell connects a whole bunch of
others and when one fires it sort of goes
down and write and then little synapse
fires and it triggers another one.
We all have some vague sense of, okay,
neurons are in our brain and they,
and they sort of wired together
and they fire together.
So now if you want to simulate one
of those in a very simplistic way,
in a way that you like imagined the
programmers back in the eighties and I had
pretty not very powerful computers,
well how could you make
a computer like brain?
Well we don't need all that complexity.
Maybe we don't need all the details
of ion channels in synapses and,
and all the neurotransmitter chemicals
that are artifacts of our biology.
What really is the essence
of what's going on here?
And the essence is something activates it,
fires,
it's connected in a network to some
others. And if there's enough, you know,
inputs that are firing
and beyond a threshold,
then then downstream neuronal fire too.
So the simple idea is if I,
to recap is neurons fire.
They're wired to other ones.
You sum up all your inputs,
everything that's connected on the input.
There's like thousands of inputs. And if
it crosses some threshold, then you fire.
That's it. And then, then you
just lay on tons of these.
And so the deep learning is having more
and more of these layers instead of just
like one or two or three layers having
scores of these layers and a variety of
other algorithmic advances.
But really the biggest breakthrough is
has been that we have a lot of data today
that we have back in the
80s from the Internet, from
Mechanical Turk, you name it,
all kinds of data sets to train on.
Um,
like if you want to pictures of cats with
the label, that's a cat. That's a dog.
I mean that's obviously they would
take it for granted. Like, oh,
of course you want a million of those.
You want to billion,
how many pictures of cast? One
right in the eighties. Good luck.
You could spend your whole career trying
to get a good data set to train these
neural networks with them. Plus we didn't
have digital cameras. I mean it's like,
it's crazy if you think how little
data we had an eighties. Okay,
so data is the first. The
other is, um, gps from nvidia.
They started about 10 years ago.
It wasn't a side project in scientific
computing realizing abuse, right?
So any gamer would be like,
I want the latest to play my video
games to do all these polygon renderings
offloaded from your main computing chip,
the Intel chip usually off on the
side where it used to be a peripheral
processor, a coprocessor,
an afterthought if you will,
that only gamers cared about if
you were a business computing user,
you in the old days in the 90s you
didn't care about your Gpu, right?
And he only cared about was your CPU
the thing that computes your excel
spreadsheet or whatever your database.
But the GPU people were like pushing a
whole different kinds of computational
math forward, which was on a lot
of math. Like a lot of polygons.
The more polygons, the more
you know, sort of you know,
resolution you have in your game.
And so when a very exciting way
with a different objective function,
not do a program that a human
wrote faster and faster,
but take the same damn simple math of
basically it turned out to be made what's
called Matrix multiply.
And add,
multiply a whole bunch of numbers together
and add them up, multiply, add them up.
It's like that core multiple
sort of mathematical operation.
The more you could do,
the better your graphics were.
And so they had an economic incentive
to really push the envelope where if you
asked, let's say in the
eighties or nineties, what else
could that be used for it?
The answer was, well, nothing, right?
That, that just does graphics, cds,
I totally optimized for
rendering graphics. Right?
But somewhere along the way people
realized, well, wait a second,
there's other areas in the scientific
community worldwide. By this I mean,
let's say modeling the weather,
you know, modeling how, you know,
nuclear explosions occur in government
labs where they were like, you know,
we do a lot of that matrix multiply and
add to can we try to see if we could use
it? And so it was like a
skunkworks project management
had no resources against
this.
I knew actually one of the first four
customers working on this r and d area of
all things to model how neurons fire,
um, scientific model model model.
How Neuron Actually,
oh,
how actual biology of a neuron down to
as much detail as possible coming to call
it evolves machines. And uh,
they were using gps and I,
and I remember years ago seeing, wait,
you just bought for $2,000 at the local,
we call it was Fry's and
then Fry's electronics store.
You just bought more power than any
supercomputer of just two years ago for
$2,000 because of this domain.
Right?
So this incredible computer resource
was pushed to the limits from gaming.
And I think almost poetically when you
think about rendering three dimensional
worlds in making the photorealistic,
you're doing something our brain
does exquisitely well, right?
We get an avalanche of information on
our retina, in our CORTEX and wheat down.
Scale that to image recognition,
building over there, your face,
the symmetry of your eyes and,
and,
and much like a neural network when you
train them. It recapitulates our biology,
it builds edge detectors
and then symmetry detectors.
And then I face things and you,
cause you can probe what's been built a
little bit and get a sense, oh my God,
it just recapitulated the sensory
cortex in an artificial system.
That's when the recapitulated meaning
recreate it from scratch. It's an analog,
sorry. Cause you're just training it like
a baby gets born, right. Opens its eyes,
starts learning. Right, right.
That's the same general thing going
on with these neural networks.
The fact that it has similar layers
in his visual system as our babies do.
But it's just like, that's
when people like me like, oh
my God, this is incredible.
Right. So, um, back to, uh, the GPU thing,
what I think is poetic is that something
that in a sense is meant to be as
realistic as possible to our vision system
has the kind of computational systems
we need to in fact do vision
systems in like, let's do,
let's recognize cats and internet or
let's recognize cancer and a pathology
slide that those general constructs
occur because our brain has evolved to do
data reduction and pattern recognition
in the world in a way that is optimal for
what we do. So that when we
build these neural networks,
what do they really good at?
All the same stuff like,
and so all the applications they
are in like speech processing,
visual processing, which is the
simple stuff, the edge of our cortex.
And then naturally it's gonna start
moving into emotional systems and in the
frontal lobe and the rest
of our critical systems.
And so that's why I think it's
the obvious path to AI in the,
in the broadest sense.
So many questions. Jay, the,
I love that story for where that story
slash explanation for a number of
reasons.
One is,
yeah,
how careful one should be with dismissing
certain fields or even if they seem
trivial or a wait to be a waste
of time like gaming, right.
If you look at the byproduct
of the incentives that
drove that and then the off
label uses of GP use our gps,
I'm mistaken in thinking that they also
have a role in a cryptocurrency mining.
Oh absolutely. Right. So the, the um, the,
that's a very computationally intense
task and so it moved definitely from until
like CPU to GPU but then even went
further than I went to these field
programmable gateways.
And then the custom chips designed from
scratch and sort of it quickly went down
that path and deep learning
chips will as well.
There was one of my investment themes
the last few years is that deep learning
is doing the exact same thing.
Two custom chips.
She mentioned something much earlier.
One last thing on this.
So you gotta take a Nvidia summarize
something amazing and also out of Google
did a paper,
the majority of code at Google
now is built by a computer,
not by human.
Cause that's one weird way of summarizing
this is when you train a neural
network, you're not coding, you know,
if then else you're setting up the
same thing you set up every time.
I mean that's to fungible. It's a
very fungible skill set, by the way.
And you train it and use the computers
generating its own executable.
At the end of the day,
the majority of programming is that
way now by by a factor of 10 so wild.
Yeah. And every product that Google
embodies it from search to you name it,
it's like that is the
key technological things.
Striping across every Google product.
So you're so excited by the science,
by the engineering.
You mentioned product manager while
back and you did in fact do that for a
period of time. Right. So Yep.
What I've observed, not always,
but very often at least did
when I lived in Silicon Valley.
Certainly that a lot of engineers have
a severe disdain or at the very least a
distaste for all things. Most things
marketing related. Right, right.
It's just, I remember that HP, just
a bunch of like hand waving. Yeah.
The shyness them, I mean hell yeah. So
many levels. So, so what, why did you,
with the background, you have set
your sights on product managing.
Yeah, so I remember exactly how this
happened. I was at I getting that right,
product management, product
marketing, product management,
that's actually the word I
was looking for. Sorry. In,
in different firms use the terms
differently, but I was open to both. Um,
some cases it's more engineering
rich, other cases, it's whatever.
So when I was at HP,
I was in chip design and marketing was
in a different building as it often is.
And I basically was getting frustrated
even though it was not there very long on
what I saw all around me,
at least at HP,
which was where promote from
within culture, you know,
over 20 years it'll become an engineering
manager. And he's like, you know,
most people, they were lifers as we
call them. And that seem kind of long.
It's like I really, really dedicate the
rest of my life to that career path.
And then I was like, well,
how can I accelerate this?
And that's one of the first idea came off.
I somewhat got into marketing and had,
you know,
it seemed like the boss has more than
just one narrow functional domain.
Like I mean,
yeah,
she gets an experience over there and
then I'd be more of an engineering manager
if I could know more than just my
narrow bear end of engineering.
I thought being in a dream manager was
the end goal and learning a bit about
marketing and product marketing
because that was the mystery. Like how,
how are all these decisions that
seem to implicate, you know,
the sort of impact our product development
cycles and products it and canceled,
you know, things succeeding or failing
in the market. That seemed important on,
on what I was doing and not just didn't
make a breakthrough. So I wasn't,
I guess you could say I wasn't a scientist
in my profession of well I'm just
doing it to learn the
best way to do something.
I was engineering the through and through,
which is I want to have an impact.
I don't want to design a widget that's
going to sit in a room and they will get
used just cause I like to design widgets.
It's like it really would love to have
something to be meaningful in the world.
And so that's why I thought about that.
And yes,
there was a big disdain for marketing,
uh,
amongst the engineers
that I worked with and uh,
and I did finally get
the chance that that is,
I wanted to work with Steve Jobs as well.
So I got a chance to work at apple and
next software it's called next is when
they were moving out of the hardware
business into the software only. So,
but next as it was called, um, and I would
leave wasn't for me either though. Uh,
I just didn't,
some things just didn't click about.
I think maybe in my short attention span
and my interest in diverse things, uh,
that hunkering down to any one thing
in committing to do it for five years
seemed anathema to my s my course.
That's why I left the phd
program after two quarters.
And like I'm not going to
write a thesis that's like,
like spent four years on one little
narrow area of actually neural networks
would have been my thesis area,
specifically neural networks and played
the parallel processing computers was
what I was starting down.
Uh,
I would have been fascinated by
that but it would have been 20,
20 years too early. Um, anyway. Uh,
same thing in any operating job.
It's like I would be either job
hopping the way some people do, um,
who have this problem I have or I'd have
to be on Hattie I think in my job cause
it just the pace of change and
learning would stagnate so quickly.
I could see these patterns over months,
not years that like I'm not learning
them as much anymore and they just
executing the same thing
over and over again.
And so management consulting was
an interesting way to play to that.
And like all kinds of
different client engagements,
it just didn't have the same agency
of making a meaningful impact.
You could point to sure. Very
vicarious, very diffused and ambiguous.
Whether you've accomplished anything.
And so that's why all the management
solving from say we, you know,
adding value all was talking about mad
at and you're measuring how much value we
added.
All these things are being said because
everyone knows in their heart and I
can't tell them any value.
How do I know if it was me or that it's
usually then we can't really sing our
own praises that much. So, um, so I love
the diversity of management consulting.
I didn't like the life balance
nor the agency. And so when,
when finally I discovered venture
capital and learned what it was about,
it was like the perfect combination
for me. Well, your investment, uh,
or at least that facet of
things you haven't seen the,
the Lens of looking for things
you haven't seen before. Right?
That's where that also speaks right into
that. Your programming, so to speak.
You can see maybe that's the origin.
I hadn't connected those dots.
But it seems obvious now
as I say this to you,
that that desire to seek something new
may have been a driver of that simple
rule that I've been living my life by it,
which is an injustice. Something that,
uh, you haven't seen before. So when
you, when you're looking at companies,
and I am going to come back to Steve Jobs,
I have some questions about
Steve and Ilan. I know you,
you've spent a good amount of time both,
uh,
when you're looking at these
companies that have no product,
that are in the idea stage,
I mean there may be some white papers
or publications from think tanks or
conference panels that
discuss these subjects. Uh,
how do you evaluate deals
or how do you vet deals?
Because I've seen a lot of people
attempt to go as early as you do,
but have just gotten their faces
ripped off routinely. Right? So, yeah,
I mean there's, there are and it
particularly if you're trying to be bold,
so not just invest at the early stage
but also go for things that are,
how are times, however many times
out of 10 going to fail. Uh,
how do you avoid running out of bankroll?
Right.
I mean I'd love to just hear
a little bit about what you,
what you look for in a situation
like that at that embryonic stage.
What are the check boxes that
help you to risk mitigate,
if that's even a consideration though
is um, well, sort of risk mitigation.
Windex spray. Yeah. This is the last one.
How many up cause but part of the luck I
had in starting in the best dinner sort
of economic boom for venture, you
could imagine the.com boom, right?
No small amounts of capital hello
companies to scale incredibly rapidly.
There wasn't really historical precedent
for something that good for venture
capital.
So chock part of this up to luck.
But the side effect then lasted is
that I didn't have that fearful moment.
I didn't slog through 10 years of just
banging my head against the wall of
failure, failure, failure, failure.
It just was like shooting fish
in a barrel to start, right?
So that I think helped me a build enough
track record that people would give me
a bit more slack to pursue something
right within my partnership, for example,
to pursue ideas that,
that I can't imagine what life would be
like how I was stuck in a partnership
that wouldn't give me credibility or
let me run with some ideas. Right.
And they certainly would push
back, believe me, Oh, space.
The next bunch of companies like
really you're going to doesn't rugged.
So you kidding me? So I get, I'd
have to defend some of these,
but I didn't get the, no, no,
no, you can't do this. Right.
So that if I hadn't had that capacity to,
in other words, to avoid the inner voice
of doubt and the overt expert, a critic,
right.
And both internal and external,
I don't think I could've done what I did
in the, in the subsequent years. So, um,
fast forward to let's say midway through
my career into the present day. Um,
so was the startup phase is a little
different than the steady state.
So now that we're in a steady
state and I can realize, okay,
there'll be some failures,
that's fine in what I then look for is a
combination of some personal attributes,
marketing attributes and weirdly of late
sort of process technology attributes.
So I would have in the past said,
oh,
technology breakthrough of course there
has to be, you know, people, you know,
huge market and something disruptive in
the technology domain that didn't like
to nanotechnology or something that like
we couldn't have done this five years
ago.
Oh that's another question I always ask
every entrepreneur either explicitly or
implicitly if I know the
answer I need to ask it,
which is could you start this business
five years ago? And if the answer is yes,
then I don't want to invest. What are
their questions? What are other questions?
One I love to ask is,
so what does this business look
like in 10 years and 20 years out?
And what is mind boggling is unfortunately
how this weeds out the charlatans and
the, you know, arbitrage seeking
opportunities like nothing else.
Or they just like deer in the headlights.
They never thought 10 years or 20
years old, they don't have any idea.
And it's not because things change so
rapidly that you can't predict 10 or 20
years so that they don't have a mission,
they don't have a purpose for why
they're starting their business. Right.
If you ask Elon Musk that he knows
right away, he has planet labs,
he knows right away,
yes Zuckerberg,
he knows right away you ask Larry
Page and Larry and Sergei Brin,
they know right away what their business
looks like in 10 and 20 years and they
have a mission statement that they hold
to throughout their entire life and it
galvanizes the team. It
motivates them to, you know,
that's why they're in business.
Other people that are,
I call them arbitrize seekers,
uh,
when people flock from some industry
cause there's gold in the hills,
you want to weed that out, this is a great
way to weed that out, right? He's just,
people don't tend to have
long term visions if they
don't really have a purpose
for what they're doing. Um,
so, uh, so on the people side,
I increasingly have become enamored
with purpose driven businesses as I was
mentioning or mission driven businesses
were making money is not the prime
objective.
It's the byproduct of the way they
intend to change the world to usher in,
you know,
the transition to sustainable transport
in clean energy to colonize Mars as a
couple of easily understood examples.
Those are both unique.
There aren't any other
startups at the time, you know,
proposing that to colonize Mars.
Um,
nor is it something that you get
done in a short period of time.
It's like the star on the horizon that,
that galvanizes so much action.
Do you want me to look back though
the to the, the overall categories,
the process stuff and the other little
and here about some of the attributes?
Yeah, sure. So on the
market size, I think,
I think a lot of venture investors in
the early stage would have the following
common answer to your question.
I invest in good people pursuing big
ideas in enormous markets. Right. Okay.
Um, but sometimes they actually won't
execute on that because enormous markets
usually means that it's
something really radical,
that changing.
There's a lot of unpredictability.
So if you're investing in ride sharing
as you did right before it was obviously
a good idea.
It was not obviously a good idea and most
of them people probably thought it was
a really bad idea. Well, there was a,
there was an email that a naval
Ravikant put up not too long ago, uh,
which was the, the email that
was sent out through Angel List,
which was uh,
ignored by something like
297 people out of 300.
Exactly.
It was not clearly a great idea actually.
I would say like when I first
invested in Hotmail, I felt this,
I felt that when we first invested
in Skype side note really quickly,
just cause I'm cheating, I'm cheating a
little bit here and I didn't know this.
Uh, where'd the name come from?
How much? One. Oh, hot hotmail. Um,
uh, it was spelled with a
capital h. T m. L. So it was, oh,
we're going to do web based email over
html. It's getting big age smaller. Yeah,
exactly. It was that Dorky
and uh, that was it. Yeah.
And even more interesting they,
because they are offering free email,
they put a lot of effort
into the free aspect of this.
So they located in Fremont,
California on Liberty Avenue.
They launched on the 4th of July,
which is a national holiday.
So they got no news
pickup. Yeah, that's right.
It's all free TV. So anyway,
those companies were widely
regarded as bad ideas.
Severe of hotmail famously was turned
down by 21 venture capitalist before he
found us.
And I would say without a doubt,
because I've met the number
these venture people at the time,
the series a was happening
for Ebay and Google.
The vast majority venture capitalists
would not invested in series a. In fact,
after the series they of Google that two
primary investors demanded to get their
money back. They want it to be redeemed
at cost because of a little spat.
They're having lots of
founders not getting a new CEO,
a not well known fact or one
of the major venture investors.
And apple sold their entire steak pre IPO.
You know,
they still brag about being an
investor in apple of course.
But people lose faith in the greatest
companies that have invested in a newer
bouncing around a lot. But I that that is,
that is what I like to do. So I, I was,
I was doing a bit of homework and uh,
you were very helpful in sending
me links to a few things.
One was an interview with Jason
Calacanis. Oh yeah, I love that guy.
And you had created a very
nifty index of subject on your,
on your, uh, flicker account.
And one of the bullets was why I never
sell shares of our companies and biggest
misses also. But, uh, could you
explain what you mean by that?
I'm sure we listen what is never so never,
never sell.
It's a wonderfully liberating stance.
And at first people were like, yeah,
I can see your fish. Like, wait, that
doesn't make sense. You know, buy low,
sell high is kind of a munch.
Yeah, no, I've never sold a share.
Now let me add the caveat when I have
control. So the vast majority of time, uh,
in our business this would apply,
which is we invest in a startup.
It either has an IPO or it gets acquired.
Those are the two outcomes where it
has a quote liquidity event, an IPO,
some point after the IPO, you know,
years later, or at least 180 days later,
a venture for, and we'll distribute
those shares to its investors.
So I as the general partner gets shared,
so I get shares of Tesla,
I get shares of you name it right now
what I choose to do that as my own
personal decision, right? And from
that point on, I've never sold a shirt.
Now what I do is give him
the charity over time.
And some might argue that's
kind of a sales decision,
but not entirely be partially because
it's not like I'm trying to time the
market. I'm betting on
them in perpetuity. And,
and I'll give you another answer to why
I do this. In a moment, but let me just,
let me flesh this one out a little
more. This has been wonderfully, um,
goal aligning with entrepreneurs because
if I'm thinking when is the time to
punch out?
It's kind of a corrosive thought process
when they're thinking I the ones I like
one of my, what's the next 20
years look like for this business?
How can we make the most out of
it in this next phase of growth?
Because the best companies are like
these sort of power laws of compounding
potential. They, you know,
would you want to be punching out and
you wouldn't write if Facebook or Google,
if you know, 10 years ago, God, that
would have been really bad mistake. Right.
And I love, actually, let me
jump to the point number two.
Some of the very first advice I got
when I was entering this field was from
someone who had spent their entire
career at the Rockefeller Group.
I forget what she was,
foundation or somethings and he's Peter
Crisp and I remember him vividly because
we were,
I think my first week on the job,
it was our first pitch to
people who give us money.
And here I met someone who has
just coming off a long career,
sort of winding down, slowly off a
long illustrious career investing.
Some of the best companies
you can imagine. And he's
two comments to me were, wow,
first I'm super envious.
And this young group of people that
starting your career right now,
this looks like you're going to love this.
I wish I was your age doing this again,
this whole second wave.
So I just liked it.
Here I am changing careers as we mentioned
earlier and not sure which careers
are made from me that I had
to hear something like that.
And the second thing is looking
back over his whole career,
he wished he had never sold anything
and that I had a similar reaction.
What do you mean? He goes, well,
I tried to time the market and if I had
just held onto my apple shares, right,
and who cares what it happened. Everything
else like the, as if held value today,
it would've trumped everything else.
I'd be a much richer man.
I would have avoided all that anxiety.
And that echoed in the back of
my mind to this day. So in my,
I won't show this specifics,
but in my personal portfolio there was
a similar power of mother as a single
company that's worth more than everything
else combined because I've never sold
a share.
And then if I look at number two,
may I have to actually go back and do
the math number two plus number three
probably that kind of think about it
as long tail exceeds everything else
combined. So it's like a traditional
power law and that is pretty amazing.
So I just like when I made this decision
and also around the same time to give
it all to charity.
That was another thing that created a
living trust to give everything about a
small fixed dollar amount to the kids.
Everything else going to go to charity.
Then when you have a major crashes,
it's not like,
I know this is gonna sound weird.
I don't stress it.
I just lost 90% of my net worth.
Cause that happened once. It's like,
oh the charity just lost 90%
of his net worth, you know.
And so I was able to write it through
when it came right back cause I didn't
panic and sell when I literally lost 90%.
My net worth. Um, I don't recall seeing,
I don't remember who it was,
but one of the,
and there aren't that many as you know,
uh,
but a tier venture capital
firms looked at their return on
something or they're returned
to limited partners of the,
let's just call it 10 companies that had,
uh,
reached IPO and that they
subsequently distributed.
And they compared that with the amount
made by someone who would have invested
the amount in the companies at first
opportunity at IPO and written it out
something like five years. And they would
have made just as much money in, in,
in most of the cases. Uh, yeah,
there was a fun called
technology crossover ventures
I think formed with that
insight in mind that says if you can
pick some winners still private in,
in and have a judgment from
seeing the track record,
the passion of the entrepreneur
or a number of years, and
then load up the boat,
either just pre IPO or at IPO.
Yeah.
That you can put a large amount
of capital to work in that.
But the key was it was those prior
years of exposure that really gave you
confidence.
So like my years with elan allow me to
look at him in a very different way than
other than entrepreneurs. Right. Yeah.
And if you just literally had no prior
data and he just walked in off the street,
I would, you really know.
You see, you mentioned deal.
So you spent time with jobs, Elon,
many other impressive folks. But what,
what are the commonalities
you've observed?
Biggest commonalities,
biggest differences between those two?
Sure.
Well,
let me start with differences because I
think it's tempting to draw an analogy
and I have been tempted to trust me.
Um,
but I think it's really important to
keep in mind. So I'll start there.
There's pretty big differences.
Jobs was as a marketing centric individual
with very weak engineering shops.
Uh,
Ilan is more of a physicist
turned engineer slash
computer scientist basically
deep engineering chops,
thinks of everything from first principles
of what can be done from physics and
then scales up to the product vision
jobs. It's much more of a, you know,
like almost a zen Buddhist approach too.
Parsimonious design and the and the
visceral agitation of its imperfection in
design space.
You know,
his famous calligraphy font thing and
getting rid of all the buttons from the
phone. There's all these like maniacal
missions he'd had where at no point did he
clearly lay out like,
well here's the business strategy.
Like you get rid of the buttons,
everything lives in the cloud.
You have software services layer
you can iterate more quickly.
Like this is going to be an
awesome business opportunity
from get rid of all the
buttons and things like that and say no
buttons or ugly. Get rid of them though.
That's that shit. That design is
shit. You know, he would say, um,
but it wouldn't really give this like, ah,
I get it. That's the master plan, right?
Whereas Ilan is like master plan, part
one, master plan part do in the French.
He lays it all out and he's basically
executed according to the master plan and
there's actually a really well thought
out series of steps to get from here to
colonize Mars, a series of steps to
get rid of the petrochemical economy,
which is pretty amazing.
And it's all there for anyone through EAD.
That's like night and day difference.
Now, similarities, simple one, you know,
CEO of two companies. I think that's
interesting. Structurally, uh,
not too many people have the shuts
but to do that and I think by the way,
in both cases it allows you to focus
interestingly in a way that you couldn't
have ice. You're saying, sorry, I heard
that sentence to the CEO. Two companies,
each of them independently,
CEOs of two companies.
[inaudible] you got Pixar and,
and and,
and either next or apple
depending on timeframe.
To be fair jobs was really not quite
the CEO at Pixar, but he was by title.
In any case, what you can do though
is avoid meetings. Imagine, you know,
it's the company Holiday Party and
you just don't want to go, right?
No one's going to double guessing.
Like if you're normal CEO and then we'll
come and you avoid your own holiday
party. He's like, well what really,
what better thing is you have to do? Um,
but this,
this is awesome.
You can basically avoid time wasting
meetings and you have to delegate more.
And so in both cases it is an intriguing
thought experiment that being CEO more
than one company has some interesting
benefits for both companies, Huh? Yeah.
Never thought of it. That
one. Yeah. Um, the similarity,
I think there's one area
in design where the, the,
the maniacal attention to detail.
I'm, I, I described it as this,
this visceral agitation that,
I mean almost painful to Steve jobs
to see things that were not right. Um,
there's a bit of that in any line as well.
I interviewed him once about
design and it sounds so spooky.
We still similar in that regard,
but in a completely different wrapper,
meaning you wouldn't really know or
see it as a similar vector of like,
like both think it's just easy and maybe
it's a sign of brilliance, but it just,
there's certain parts of this whole
space that are intuitive and they do
naturally. And I wish I knew how to a
do it myself and be spotted and others,
right. So everyone wants
to, wants to ask like,
how can I raise my kid to be like
Elon? Or how can I, you know,
find entrepreneurs that are like him.
And if you,
if you think about just one element of
that and how miraculous it is to be able
to go into a number of industries,
you know, commercial banking,
are you leave with paypal,
the aerospace industry with space x,
the automotive sector, um, the, you know,
the energy competing with utilities,
with the solar city idea, really
left field. Now it's part of Tesla.
But when it started, it was really a left
field sector. It wasn't one industry.
I was like, well, that's
energy generation.
That's like competing with
regulated utilities. Um,
without any prior business experience
in those sectors to become the dominant
company in all of them,
to have failed at none of them,
to be the most important company in all
those fields is kind of mind boggling.
So as an immigrant, I forgot, right?
And the thing that I look for in companies
that say we've got this mission as I
was mentioning,
but we're going to get this through
incremental steps and engaging with
customers along the way.
We're not just going to like hunker
down for 20 years and then pop out with
colonizing Mars and the other end
to actually paint the picture.
How we get from here to there,
that's even more miraculous in some ways.
It's like everyone can have
a big dream like, oh yeah,
like thousands of people could
have the dreams that Elon has.
Almost none of them can paint a
compelling picture how to get there.
That's where the,
what's your 10 year vision?
What's your 20 year
vision comes into play?
So Elon has this mythical status
for so many people. I mean,
just this kind of superman who's
got everything figured out. Uh,
I found this
article on business insider that
was talking a little bit about your
relationship with him. And there are two
things. One, I'll just, uh, actually two,
two questions I'm gonna ask.
The first is called him the most
risk immune person I've ever met.
Uh, and then, then I have a
follow up to that. But what does,
what does that, what's, what's, what's
an example of him being risk immune?
Yeah.
I,
is it because he does it because he
feels differently in the face of the same
risk or is it because he defines
risk differently or something?
Yeah,
that's a great question because I think
it's passed through the filter of the
Observer. We perceive risk, incredible
risk, and some of the things he's done,
I don't know that we have perfect vision
on kind of how could we unreal. He does,
he perceive the risk the same way
we do, right. As external observers.
And so I think part of the answer and
his brother made it somewhat similar
statement once I feel comfortable
at least talking about this, uh,
not as if I'm speaking out of school that,
um,
they're like, here, here's
one I can say to externally.
I've never seen an entrepreneur go all
in for his companies and I say plural,
um, as, as Elan, like some entrepreneurial
take risks, they'll quit a job,
they'll spend their entire life savings
on some idea. They'll do whatever. Right?
The personal commitment,
personal sacrifice.
I've never seen anything like Ilan and
I think this story came out and where I
was referring back to December,
2008 yeah. This, uh, and the,
and the darkest period for Tesla.
Yeah.
So yeah, muscular. It would take 50
million to get his first trip to Mars.
And then next sentence, he was 200
million, 200 million in and had quit,
spent all of his money between that and
Tesla and he went into personal debt by
2008.
Exactly.
So 2008 for those that might remember
with financial crisis was happening for
context. At that time, Tesla had
just gotten rid of a CEO. Um,
Elan was not,
it had not been the CEO up
until then and it was tough.
A large investment bank,
one of the most prestigious had
just failed to do a fundraise.
This is where you hot hire them,
pay them lots of money,
go out and get us the money.
You know,
you expect it to come in at the end
of this process. They're like, sorry,
we have nothing for you. And the company
was rapidly running out of money.
In fact,
it was heading towards December,
2008 in and they couldn't
even make payroll.
And so Ilan wrote a check personally
for $3 million just so they can make the
December,
Christmas time payroll of the employees.
But like January is gonna be just as
bad and there's like no money anywhere.
There was. And by the way, for context,
there was no government program.
There was no Daimler
investment at this point.
It was just a company that had a
roadster that was negative gross margin,
meaning every car you sell, you lose more
money. Um, it was a surprise discovery.
How bad the proposition was is when the
CEO was let go, it was like, oh my God.
Like contrary to our belief, we're
actually losing money on every car. Um,
and that's not easy to
fix. By the way, you know,
sell more cars does not solve
this problem right? Readily. Um,
and you had your largest insight investor.
This is a term of art in
the venture community.
There's a lot of symbolism
when your largest investor
is or is not supportive of
what you're doing. It doesn't, no,
it doesn't mean they actually
have a thing that can, a lever,
they can pull that kill you are.
But the symbolisms bags that
are in the trenches with you,
and if they're refusing to write a check,
that's a really hard
fundraising environment.
And the largest investor was as
hostile as I've ever seen an investor.
They did not want Ilana CEO. They did
not want anything do with the company.
They want it to pivot to a different
business strategy that seemed a little too
cozy, that it would support
one of their limited partners.
And it felt really icky. And
they were openly hostile. So, oh,
and he was going through a divorce and
SpaceX rockets were blowing up by the way.
And he spent every penny he had.
So what does he do?
He borrowed $20 million and
he said, okay, we don't,
our lead investors not here,
this large investment bank has failed.
I'm going to invest the $40 million
that's needed. He didn't have $49. She's,
I'm going to invest the $40
million is needed to hell.
A lot of you hear the terms and
not to help, but I'm doing it.
Train's leaving the station. And it
flipped this design guys, if you will,
from fear degreed. Right? And,
and, and this is what it is.
Meaning everyone's thinking,
I want to be part of that is he see
that I don't see. And, and to be fair,
there is a, um, there is a dynamic
which I'm sure you've seen,
which is you can have a bunch of
people around the table like we were,
Dfj was very enthusiastic
and wanted to invest,
but we can't do the full 40 million and
we need somebody to be the lead investor
and we'll do our full share. Right? We
actually did more than our full share,
but somebody's got to step further this
missing nut when your largest insider
won't and you don't have any outside my,
someone's got to set them up.
So he stepped up and said,
I don't care.
I'll do the whole thing
if need be who's with me?
And we took as much as we could.
We brought our growth fund in
for the first time. Um, and it,
it is an easier decision to say, will I
write a check, let's say for $2 million.
Let's say you were just one of the random
investors there as part of 40 knowing
that at least as 40 at least we're
going to get through this roaster cost
problem and, and, and be able to
turn some cards if you will. See,
does the government through, does the
Daimler relationship actually happened?
Cause there's verbal
conversations going on.
We'll get resolution at
least those major things.
And so that there'll be hope to get to
the next phase of actually building the
model s car. If all that falls in
our favor, let's be part of it.
So our $2 million check
leverages the $40 million check.
I'm just saying to
arbitrarily, yeah. So if you,
if all you can do is
write $2 million checks,
you would never just write it to him.
The dollar check. That's like, like a,
like a peer. It's not a bridge to
something. It's like, uh, you know,
and that's what a Elon was willing to do
in December, all by himself. And then B,
he was willing to do another one
all by himself. I've never seen it.
I get so he in retrospect
was perfectly right.
Everything went exactly according to plan.
This is going to change the world.
It's going to be an
enormously valuable company.
This was eight an incredibly
good investment to make at
the time. In retrospect,
at the time it seemed like the
riskiest thing I've ever seen.
I've never seen an entrepreneur
fund their own company,
you know first when no one else would
second go net negative by $20 million.
Unbelievable. Did you, have you asked
him what he was thinking at the time?
Not Directly. I didn't
want to, I liked it.
This is great.
It just felt like the right thing is like
I could see the fear of going to greed.
By the way,
in tough times you sometimes also learn
who is going to stand by you and who
won't.
Well and so that that lead investor
and then also maybe I won't mention the
names, there's at least one board
member who was like, oh my gosh.
They showed their stripes and there's
nothing like a crisis to know if you're in
the trench with the right person, maybe
who you're a fair weather friends are.
Yeah.
To that point,
it's mentioned in this piece that you
don't call to you around the darkest times
were. And so during some of these
really tough periods, what does,
and it doesn't of course keeping it
whatever private should be private,
but what is someone like Elon and
you've interacted with a number of these
people who have incredible
capacity to do big things.
Uh, what is someone like that say to a
friend during their dark times? I mean,
why do they call friends?
So I'm not going to relay any specifics,
but I can try to get to
the gist of the question.
I won't really any specifics of the
phone call. And, and to be fair,
I don't even really remember the specifics
because I'm in so many calls over so
many times. So, so with
the caveat of, because,
because if you look at the list of
difficulties he was going through,
like any one of those, yeah. Be
Soul crushing, soul crushing.
I mean will completely paralyze and
send millions of people into a downward
spiral.
So it,
so he has said some things cause I don't
want to speak out of school but there
is something I can share
that might be helpful.
He has spoken himself and it was like
eating glass that this was like really
terrible time.
So he's made some comments personally,
I'll just let him speak for
what it felt like for him.
But I would say that what I've observed
in that crisis and other crises that we
generalize is that he goes into a
battle mode of focus that is really
remarkable.
Um,
in this battle mode is allows him I
think to ignore distraction and to have a
laser focus on what needs
to get done. So, um,
it'll sometimes be observant as these
sort of thoughtful deep moments of like,
wow. Like you see it on his face and, and
you, you want to give him space to think.
Cause I think there's like four people
that can be times when your generative
and thoughtful and brainstorming and
thinking about all possibilities and the
wonder of the world.
And other times when you're like,
you've got to like solve the problem and
like focus in, in, in, in those modes,
he can avoid distraction
like no one else I've seen.
So a lot of the smart CEOs and
entrepreneurs I've worked with are,
are some of them share
afterwards that I have in spades,
which is I'm interested in many things.
I'm easily distracted by something and
sometimes I'd rather avoid the tough
crisis in my,
you know,
in thinking about it when
there's something more fun
to spend time on. Right.
And so I'm almost the opposite of this
exist to give credit to how valuable this
says. Um, when, let's say Tesla has faced
various, um, manufacturing challenges,
these sort of production hell
times that he's described.
He physically sets up his office on the
production floor in a very visible area
with no walls.
So everyone can see that he's there
through the weekend and I'm the vice
presidency that and that ripples out.
Um, when he's calling a supplier,
let's say he was often the cause of
a problem is like Angela, like, well,
I'm here in the factory.
Where were you going?
Why aren't you here solving this word? I
said, yeah, it has a lot of impact, right?
That personal attention to right now,
everything else needs to be gone.
I'd have to solve this problem.
I witnessed this for example, uh,
in a, in a, in a more subtle way,
more recently when I was setting up
or trying to set up rather a very
interesting phone call between the
Marzano persons or the Mars exploration
program for NASA,
uh,
Craig Vendor who's a pioneer and study
biology and gene sequencing and gene
synthesis. And I want to just getting
along on a half hour call because we,
the sort of idea had occurred amongst us
that we could do a much cheaper Marzia
turned mission. In other words,
fine. If there's any life
on Mars, either, you know,
um,
archaic or currently living,
the best way to explore it would
be not to send it back from Mars,
which is very difficult.
But the Senate gene sequencer to Mars
sequence a locally beam the data back and
create the living organism on earth.
That's actually is doable.
And I thought Elan's should
certainly be inserted in this cause.
I'm like the next phase of
Mars exploration, terraforming,
finding out what organisms
do live on Mars or not.
If they mutate and margin actually
start thriving, send the data back,
create a version on earth to study, adhere
and more rapidly telephone terraform,
Mars. He's like, you know,
that's great. He said,
I can't take that from only
half hour phone call one day.
That will be important right now.
I get it, get it fucking heavy.
They fly or they won't be that need
for me to be doing that. So I'm like,
I would love this half hour phone
call with you once the three of them,
he's like that. That can wait a few
years and it can, right. Yeah. Um,
and that remarkable ability to push
aside all these interesting things when
there's, I got to get Xyz to
ship or fix the problem. Um,
and so fixing the gross margin
problem back in 2008 getting a CEO,
which didn't have to be himself,
I'm in place and solving on all the
myriad problems that were in place was
battle mode. And he would also lean on
confidence and friends. So it'd be fair.
There were others like Antonio Grassy,
us and others who really rolled up their
sleeves got on the factory floor and
close friend. Yeah, he's, he's
amazing. So folks that um,
really come and,
you know,
prove that there was some little stable
investors out there, Antonio's happy to,
to, to fight to support his
friends too. Oh, exactly.
I'll just say he's my favorite investor
I've ever met in my entire network,
so I mean get up more over, over
a bottle of wine about this. But,
so we were, Antonia and I were in
the Henry Crown Fellowship program.
The other thing that's been institutes,
we,
we've had a chest spent a lot of time
together. Um, yeah, great guy. Absolutely.
Great Guy. Said two things
come to mind. The first is,
and I'm sure I'm going to butcher this,
but I,
I hate to quote attributed to Steve Jobs.
I feel like there are a
lot of mistreated quotes.
I'm pretty sure this is accurate.
I don't think it's enabling
can situations on the Internet,
but that innovation is saying no
to a thousand things that the,
I haven't heard that
button but in any case, uh,
the other was he's also by the way jobs
was very proud of and that's what his
greatest creation or grades
contribution to the world.
Greatest invention as great. It's
thing on his death, but it was apple,
the organization and it was really the
process learning coming back to something,
I was starting to have it earlier.
He was focused on physical space design
and keeping the engineer's in the
marketing people thinking about
where the bathrooms aren't Pixar,
so you have to walk by
certain areas to get to them.
He was maniacal about architecting
the way people communicate,
kicking people out of
meetings at the too big.
So he had an intuitive sense about
team size along before I did.
And now I know that people are over a
certain weight class or you don't want
people on anything productive.
No development team.
Actually five the ideal number five
plus or minus two boards of directors,
development teams,
creative groups.
That's the one of the secret of managers
of small companies that they have less
people and they get shit
done when it's a big company,
has hundreds of people and sclerotic
layers of management that Dave lost the
small team dynamic.
So I always like to ask about,
I asked about it with Elan, uh, the,
some of the tougher times because
more challenges because it's,
it's easy I think.
And I explore this with uh,
lots of everybody who's on the show.
I tried to ask her about how they are,
how they try to deal with overwhelm or
if they feel scattered, what do they do?
And uh, it was, we talked a little
about, a little bit about Elan,
I'd love to ask you,
because you recently had an experience in,
a lot of people have in the sense that I,
and many others get their turn as
kind of the, uh, the punching bag.
If you're public facing,
I mean,
you're going to run into things and you
had an experience recently that I'd love
for you to describe if you're open to it.
And then I have some follow up questions
just about how you then reacted to it,
right. Self talk and things
like that. So maybe, uh, if,
if I could just leave it open. So, uh,
yeah, maybe it's an elephant in the room,
but in the last couple months I have
faced the most surreal experience of my
career, which is, you know, what's,
I'm 23 years of venture capital in
many before that all positive press
experiences.
And then I faced a bizarre,
so almost auto catalytic,
you know,
self-generating theme that I hosted
a sex party with my fancy, um,
in silicon valley. And at first I laughed.
Oh, there's a hilarious, you know,
as an ex geek,
you know,
growing up my whole life with
glasses and braces and what have you,
like the notion, I mean, my first
date was in college and you're like,
I really thought that
was hilarious at first.
And then it got a little more serious. I'm
like, wait, this, this is ridiculous. Um,
and, and it really, the thing
that's even when it came,
it derived from a book that came out
in February where there's no such claim
that we hosted a sex party but it's in
a chapter about sex parties that other
people had.
And we just happened to be the only party
that has been anyone mentioned by name.
And then it,
I mean if I tried to put a simplistic
spin on this or try to make sense of it,
it looks like people just didn't read
the chapter very carefully and they wait
blog posts or other like very sort of
nonprofessional postings online that oh my
gosh, the sex party who was at
Steve's house. And I'm like,
well what she not only did the
book not say that it wasn't true.
And by the way,
there's 150 people that attended this
thing that no one's not true and like 10
of them go publicly on,
which is kind of a risky thing to do is
say I was at this party and there was no
sex. Like including Ilan
and I, Elon Musk is like,
this is irresponsible journalism.
Or something to that effect.
And he condemned the writer and like,
like,
and it's kind of bizarre because I know
this author, I've been on her, you know,
Bloomberg television program many times.
She knows my email,
she knows my cell phone.
She never called me for a fact check,
which I didn't realize in
book publishing today, uh,
in what's ostensibly a nonfiction
category that the publishers do.
No fact checking.
And that's just a fact
now it's transformed from
decades ago and they leave it
up to the writer and the writer just blue
just didn't even try to see how it was
true and more disturbingly would retweet
even though she never said we had a sex
party. She would retweet other
people who did. So some, you know,
other publication in Europe would
say, oh the, the orgy, right?
So it starts to grow the orgy at our house
and she retweets it really, you know,
this isn't true.
And I know she knows it isn't true,
but she keeps re tweeting it
because it sells more books.
And I know executives for example,
who've been pressured by their PR people
to say positive things about the book
because of her ongoing role
is a Bloomberg reporter.
So you have this weird conflict of
interest when you want to sell books and
salacious stories sell to propagate
something that's not true.
Even if you didn't say it yourself and
then turn around and use your leverage
and your bully pulpit on Twitter and
elsewhere to gain support for your book.
Because you know,
people want to continue working with you
and you're going to be the journalist
of record in the tech industry at one
of the biggest news organizations.
It's kind of unfair. Feels
really horrible. Yeah.
Well I was going to ask
you like how did it,
how did it feel and what was your
self talk may be in the short term.
And then I ask a lot of people about
self-talk, uh, which I'm fascinated by it,
right?
So sort of the day of,
let's just say when it ceases
to be funny and then maybe,
I don't know,
I'm making this up in terms of timeline,
but like a few days later when you've had
a chance to maybe gather your thoughts
a bit. Yeah. So despite the initial
burst, almost like a defensive Aha,
this is funny, you know, and then
when I really allowed it to sink,
they probably took some number of hours.
I'm like, wait a minute, this, you know,
like for example,
the 150,
probably more until about 150 that really
knew there was nothing there and they
were there the whole time.
They had to explain to their
spouses and others are like, no,
I really wasn't at a sex
party. It's really embarrassing
when those poor people,
totally innocent. Um, anyway, and again,
not to condemn a sex party. I mean,
and there've been invited to one,
I'd never held one.
I don't want to say it's a terrible thing.
I'll just say I haven't been the one,
I don't want to be accused of one.
Right.
Well just as to inject
some levity real quickly.
So I just moved to San Francisco,
this was a long time ago. And uh,
one of my neighbors said, oh,
welcome to the neighborhood.
You should come over Saturday like
we're having a party. I was like, sure,
no problem. So, uh, I ended up like
having a late dinner. I'm like, okay,
it's too late. No, it's not too late.
Come on over. So I walk in and I'm like,
what's happening here?
Like people in various states of
undress and a just in time to realize,
oh my God, I'm actually at a sex
bar. Like there's food served,
but I'm like fully clothed with a
beanie and a and a and a Hoodie on.
And then they go,
okay,
everybody sit down and we're going
to do a round of introductions.
And so I sit down and like, wait, how do
I get out of this? Cause they're like 40,
50 people there.
And a,
I did manage to scurry out and then
then say to my neighbor, uh, wow,
I won't name by name, but I was just
like, please in the future, let me know,
give me a heads up like,
and I have nothing against it,
but it's like let me know
what's going on in any case.
So that's like you're in the
bay area, right? So it's like,
I'm sure these things happen. I literally
invited to one. It's not my thing. So, um,
so I don't want to sound too
preachy because you know,
but it's just not my thing.
And it does feel weird to have a room
full of tech executives and some of our
closest business colleagues, scores of
them, um, maligned in this indirect way.
So,
um,
the way I felt though is I felt
really betrayed and there were,
and it wasn't just a single journalists
that I've highlighted, like, wow,
what happened to professional
journalistic ethics?
It's like just fact checking
and caring about the truth.
That's one branch of disappointment. The
other was, um, a little more invisible.
I'll keep this anonymous,
but there were a number of people I
noticed who would immediately lend support
to this idea online.
Like either simple things like you know,
retweeting something without
checking with me. You know,
people who extensively know me.
Um, that was really disappointing.
So I felt betrayed by
luckily only a handful.
I mean a remarkably small
number of people who just,
and frankly there was somebody
at least well known context.
So these aren't close personal
friends that are like mid state,
other venture capitalists lists.
I just as a category,
you know on the other side I was blown
away by the outpouring of support by
people who do know me. So
a couple of um, you know,
coworkers of ex employees that I used
to work with came out with blog posts.
And in every case it was
after they published that I
even knew they were putting
something together and
coming in my defense,
it's like a female entrepreneurs
of all types. You're like, no,
it was anything but this happened at this
event and we'll be eternally grateful
for again, when, when
time is really tough,
you find out a bit more about people's
character and you find out who is really
someone who knows. You get somebody who
knows me knows is not true. Right. And uh,
what's weird is that I thought
that'd be obvious for larger set,
but at least the ones who really know me,
they don't even need to ask about it.
Oh my God, dude, what's
going on? This is crazy.
What prevented you,
I mean you had the outpouring of support.
You also had a few people
show their true colors.
Some people when they get hit with
something like that, anything,
I mean I've had periods where it's like,
I remember this kind of hit
piece came out on me. Uh,
and I'm not saying these
are the same thing,
but like it's hippies came out on me and
it came out on my birthday at one point
where I have it,
I have this annual gathering of my closest
friends and it was through a credible,
I mean a very well known publication that
had not only they had contacted me for
fact checking via phone,
I had corrected a bunch of misquotes and
then they ran it as is without making
any of the changes and it really bummed
me out like I was considering not doing
any interviews ever in the future.
Maybe I'll have to make a
number of changes to my life
so that I'm not a exposed
and I think that there are certain ways
you can mitigate like always doing fact
checking email, email responses as
opposed to be a thousand. They can't deny.
You always direct it to email.
I mean there are a number of different
ways that you can risk mitigate there, but
was there,
was there anything that you said to
yourself or the other people said to you
that was particularly helpful at the time?
Let me think about that
for a second. Um, well the,
the thing that jumps to mind is how
supportive my fiance Genevieve was
throughout this.
I mean,
she's a fighter and she was at my side
throughout in some ways it was incredible.
Um, and I'm incredibly thankful
for her support throughout.
This is the beginning
of what you were saying.
The part that it was going through my
mind as you were asking the question is
that one of the toughest things in it
relates to advice other people gave me was
the advice to not say anything.
The advice to be just mum.
I got advice from people who focus on PR.
I got advice from people who've been
through similar situations or worse,
I've been accused of crazy
things or like crimes, right?
Falsely accused of crimes. Uh, which
luckily I've never been accused of. Um,
and in every single case
like with like zero crack of,
there's another side to this point
of view is like you say, nothing,
you do not point out the obvious flaws in
these false accusations. In the, in the,
in the,
in the research supporting this is
disturbing but true that anything you say
even definitively proving your innocence
will only worsen people's perception of
you at large.
Just the mere recanting or resurfacing
of that topic to then say it has been
decidedly proven false.
It will make people think worse of
you on average now from from media
perspective. So in private
conversations that that's not the case.
And I've asked psychologists about this,
I don't know all of the studies like real
clinical slash science driven studies
show that you do not to say anything.
Even the prove your own essence.
So that's horrible,
right?
It's like that's where you're torn up
with all the virtual conversations you'd
like to have with the people who've
done you wrong with the media.
It cause you know,
you can set the record straight.
It's like I wrote pages of
stuff that I never used.
Like well let's just set the
record straight like I can I,
my mind played for months. It
would play through, you know? Well,
here's what I would say that with
just either a, clear it all up or B,
get back at the person who I know is
being dishonest to prove they're being
dishonest right now. Fess up
like you own this one. Yeah.
So that is the most difficult.
I really had a hard time with
that because in every ad,
that aspect of my life
I don't have to do that.
You can speak openly about
like I disagree with you.
Well that didn't really happen or
that's a science based fact, you know,
or something like x scientist. I hate
that. It's so it seems like this,
I mean you were able to
withstand the flak very well.
If you think back on,
it could be at any point in your life,
but has there ever been a particularly
difficult period for you? I mean,
and that you know,
I mean my whole high school I could say,
but that was a long retracted series of
pain of just feeling insecure and like
that was a late bloomer. I mean, they
sort of, I can tell you about tough times,
but there wasn't like a shock to the
system and it wasn't like, I mean,
I was deeply hurt when my dad
died. I mean that, that was tough,
but it was something that's, that's
life. It was a natural cause, you know,
I'm not Paul Funds, so it was tough. Yeah.
I mean I remorse and so I've
gone through some tough things,
but nothing that was quite
like this, which is, yeah. Wow.
That really someone did me wrong. Yeah.
I had been betrayed as opposed to, yeah.
You know,
life has its cycles and I can feel sad
about the passing of a dear loved one,
but it's a different category I think.
Yeah. No, totally different categories.
But the, I'm interested still
in the coping mechanisms or the,
the thinking that goes with it.
So when your dad died, uh, no,
I'm sorry for your loss. Um,
and it's hard for me to imagine,
but what was most helpful
during the period of grieving
or recovering from that?
It wasn't,
I didn't have a playbook of what
to do and what seemed most natural,
and it may have been the habit of mind,
was to focus on my mom and helping her.
Yeah. Uh, who survived him, who was
there. I decided when he passed, um,
of a heart attack. Um, it's just
one of those things where like,
why you're trying to revive him,
you're trying to call nine one one for,
I was like,
oh,
my heart went out so much to her and how
her situation was worse than mine in a
way that that consumed almost all my
thoughts for some period of time dealing
with,
you know,
I'm the only child in that family
dealing with what needs to be dealt with.
They just,
I want it to sort of almost nonemotional
operations mode and may have been
sometime late that night or the
next day that I finally was.
I allowed myself to cry, um,
and really face what I had lost.
Part of what gave incredible solace is
perhaps some wisdom I could pass on to
others who worry about parents who go
and I know Tim urban and others have
written some wonderful pieces about,
you know, thinking about your parents,
if you have anyone near
our parents' generation,
like how many days do you have left
with them yesterday? The tail end? Yes.
Everybody should read it.
Absolutely.
It was recommended to me just as a
quick side note by Matt Mullenweg,
mutual friend,
favorite people,
wonderful person who also lost his father
not too long ago and he recommended it
to me before it happened.
Exactly.
So maybe the thing that I took
solace in that I'll share for others,
it's not what you do and the
weeks before someone passes,
it really defines your relationship. It's
what you've done over your, your life.
And so I had been going to the Ted
Conference. I brought him with me.
It was just one of the greatest
joys of his life for years prior.
The fact that we had all
those weeks together,
sort of these one on one
times of intellectual pursuits
in this in a way almost
a welcome into my world.
Like take dad to workday in a sense in
this sort of sort of virtual world of
like ideas and science technology.
Um, when he, he went through his, uh,
he went through a pancreatic
surgery procedure and uh, uh, uh,
just around Thanksgiving
and came out of it.
And then I was told by the nurse who
first saw him when he came out of it.
Was that because there was a chance he
would make it even through the procedure?
I get to go to Ted again. It was like
the first piece. That's, that's all.
That's amazing.
It's so hearing that then,
and then he had complications a few
weeks later that he passed from.
But just knowing how much that meant to
him and how much time I did get to spend
with them purposefully,
it was really took the edge off.
Like if we were estranged,
if I was at odds with him than I had
really I think be torn up with guilt of
having not come to closure and we
had nothing. I mean, he's my hero.
I've only had positive thoughts
about him filling my life,
so I made it easier ironically to lose
the guy that I had the best relationship
with. Yeah, I mean this is like, as
you said, it's part of the cycle. Um,
I'm certainly not looking forward to
it. I mean, people will ask me like,
what do you fear? What are you
afraid of? And there, you know,
there are certainly things, uh, not,
not as many as one might expect. I mean,
I don't want to be eaten
by sharks or anything,
but I don't spend a lot of time
dwelling on the fear of that happening,
that just watching my parents get older
and ultimately pass away is something
that I, yeah, I think qualify
as definitely something
that occupies my mind and I,
oh, Matt, a huge debt of gratitude
because he led me to the tail end.
I read the tail end and that led me
a number of years ago to start taking
extended trips with my
parents, uh, twice a year.
So at six month intervals we have
not just the trip, which is usually,
let's just call it two to three weeks,
but uh,
where I usually take them
somewhere they haven't been,
but also the entire period in between
during which we can look forward to the
trip and plan the trip and talk
about the trip and that anticipation,
I feel like hiss or 70, 80% of
the enjoyment of it. Exactly.
And so I had a huge thank you
and he recommended a book to me.
I haven't yet read, but
um, I'm hoping to soon,
which I believe is on grief and grieving.
Um, and uh, he's been on the podcast
that people look up his last
name and grief and grieving.
Sure. The correct title,
if that isn't,
it will pop up.
But he recommended that everyone read
it even before passing of loved ones.
So we talked about Matt Mullenweg,
I pinged him to ask him what subjects
or questions might be interesting to
explore. And one of them was
parenting. So it's, it's a good segue.
How do you think about parenting or do
it maybe doing it differently is too
awkward question to answer,
but what are some of the things that
you think are important in parenting?
Well, you know, we don't really get
manuals on how to do it. Yeah. The people,
young parents,
the first time parents are sort of thrust
into it and then you find your own way.
The thing I,
the only thing I did to prepare for being
a parent was to read scientists in the
crib by Alison Gopnik.
It's a not a parenting book.
It's basically about the neuroscience
of infants and uh, you know,
through two and three years old
that made it fascinating to study.
And I mean literally this incredible
creature when they were pre verbal,
it sort of created a
bond that some dads lack.
I think when they don't have that
physical connection and you know,
say in nursing or what have you,
that a mom might have and yet to marvel
at this, this is creation that, uh,
is in front of you.
The things like how they pick up language,
how they envision system develops it.
That actually gave me straight,
I'm going to under strange rat hole here,
but it gave me strange
stranger experiments to run,
like pushing the bassinet on the first
day of life under a light overhead that
was an l shape and the baby's
eyes would open immediately.
Every time I went over there cause he
could actually see it through the closed
eye and any edge detection just fires up
the brains. I was like, she had visitors,
hey watch this puffy, the eyes open. Um,
and then during phony and development,
meaning learning language,
practicing Buh Buh sounds cause it's like,
it's sort of,
we take it for granted but we learn
how to speak by watching others.
Like what are you doing with your
lips to make that sound right?
So it made young childhood development
easy. Then I got into my groove,
which is like my power alley,
which is playing with like kids
getting down at their level,
whether it's Legos or blocks or whatever.
And just exploration and fun.
So what I loved about being a parent
in the early years was an excuse to
rediscover Mindstorms NXT or commercial
lego's in general. Then Mindstorms,
which got so much better.
The toys have gotten so much better
drones and I'm looking right,
so when the kids are older,
but basically playing with kids to me is
super invigorating and metaphorically,
uh, I think a lot of engineers,
scientists and people close to that field,
like even venture capitalists would do
well to try to be creative like a child
to engage like a child does with the
world. Well in that childlike wonder.
Yeah. Not to interrupt, but this,
this brings to mind and
just for longtime listeners,
the reason that I'm not going to ask a
lot of my rapid fire questions that I
normally do is because Steve,
you were kind enough to answer how good
a good number of them in my last book,
tribe of mentors.
But in that I asked you what you would
put on a billboard and you said celebrate
the child. Like mind. Yeah. So I,
I mean I don't want to interrupt
the discussion with parents.
It's almost like a mantra
came out of parenting,
which is, I could see how, and
then this is something by the way,
that hearkens back indirectly to
this book scientist in the crib,
that babies are like scientists.
They form conjectures and hypotheses.
They test the world of an inverse
to putting things in their mouth.
They're playing with everything.
Sometimes it frustrates a parent,
but when you see them as scientists doing
experiments and learning how the world
works from a sort of boot up phase,
it is metaphorical for what we lose
after oftentimes after many years of
traditional education that can
beat the creativity out of you.
And I think the best engineers in the
best scientists have that kind of a
childlike mind. You can see it in the
writings of fine mine and find it.
And even Einstein and Newton and others
like Newton I think once famously said,
I felt like nothing but a child
playing on this on the shoe store. Um,
that there's something
deeply resonant about, um,
seeing the conductivity and things as a
child would and avoiding the strictures
and mental ruts that academic disciplines,
foster and job sort of tracks.
I think about discipline,
track.
Those are both two things I don't like.
I'd rather have less discipline
and less tracks, right?
I'd rather be exploratory
and creative. And so, um,
I found children and to be
a wonderful opportunity,
it's in such a wind when
you're connecting with them,
you're mindful of your presence and
that later rolls into reading with them.
And I spent a lot of time and tried to,
whenever I'm with them,
do what they like to do,
right.
Engage with them in the kinds of toys
and things that they like and then push
that a little further with all kinds
of, uh, uh, actually put it, you know,
tech infused adjuncts to what they
might normally be playing with. We,
we probably don't have time to go into it
right now on in this conversation, but,
uh, people working, people learn about
your rocket. Oh, rocket building.
So I did a short ted talk on the,
the joys of rocketry or, yeah,
I think it's called the joys of rocketry.
Uh, so ever since my son turned three,
we started launching motto rockets.
I in this story there was,
I just went to a local toy store back
when they had them, um, you know,
physical place and saw this
Estes rocket kit, you know,
ready to fly. I'm like, wow,
I sorta remember rockets and has little,
I wasn't that into them.
I built a couple. Um, and so we did
this. And to make long story short,
I found a mentor that could teach me like,
you know,
you can get really bigger engines in
bigger rockets to f to the present day.
I've probably launched
thousands of rockets.
I Three d print these designs is to my
son and I have been working on this.
We got to the black rock desert every
year and launch like really big things
going well, past supersonic speeds, uh,
routinely, um, launching large rockets.
The rockets he could fit
inside, um, as a, as a hobby.
That's by the way where he
first met planet labs was
out in the desert launching
rockets as an aside. So occasional
good business comes out of it too.
But most of all it's this
incredible hobby of um,
making science real light
when something fails,
launched or explodes
in the pad or you know,
comes back in because the parachute
didn't deploy properly. Um,
it is just visually exciting.
I don't know, I just,
I can't really put my finger on why
it's not universally exciting to me.
It just feels like something
everyone should do a little bit of.
So tongue, my main science real,
there were, there were a few
tidbits that I pulled from one of your,
your indices on various talks and uh,
they were just seemed like fantastic
attention grabbing headlines that they're
not intended to be, that
I was like, you know,
I'd be interested in hearing the answer
or just a little bit of elaboration on
this one was drones and how to
eliminate the TSA. So what's,
what's the short ish?
It doesn't have to be super short,
but explanation of what that means. Sure.
And so the Jones' thing is peripheral,
but how to eliminate the TSA
was an epiphany I had back,
I think it was around 2005,
uh, or maybe earlier, maybe 2003,
um, post nine 11 TSA is, you know,
God in full effect doing all
kinds of crazy things. You know,
I think they just implemented the shoe
thing, you know, for the first time.
And I met this sort of brainstorming
effort with them where they gave us the
challenge,
you know,
how can we rapidly are
radically streamline airport
security operations to get
on the plane sooner. And this was
at the time looking at 18 years,
I don't know why, 18 years, maybe
it was 2002 and it'd be 2020 maybe.
Maybe it was 2002. Okay. And so I came to
that, I think it was only tech guy there.
Um, the only, well 18 years, that's
a long time to predict things.
We'd invested by the way in some
airport security technology stuff,
but I didn't really talk about
any of that. I was like 18 years,
that's going to be, you know,
perhaps 18 doublings of Moore's law,
which would be 256,000 x compute power.
Hmm.
What might someone do then that they
couldn't do? Now we'll autonomous flight.
It was like, there's a lot, by the
way, as long before autonomous driving,
autonomous flight or drones was a thing.
Um, that those words didn't exist,
at least not in the vernacular
products. And I said, well,
there's no question that we could
have a Thomas flight by then.
18 years in the future about your 20,
20 like autonomous planes.
Cause we already can today. Right?
By the way, Airbus and Boeing,
every one of those planes can
land better than the pilot.
Good and take off everything. But taxing
is easy compared to autonomous driving.
Any case, um, no one else was on
that page. And I said, well wait,
do you guys what happened?
Is there no cockpit?
They made that a really
nice first class lounge.
The plane can't be used as a weapon,
right? So why have any security gateway?
Right? So just what you could do
instead is go in with some biometrics.
We know who's on the plane,
have video surveillance in the plane as
the trade off and bring whatever weapon
you want on the plan. This would be a
really bad place to go kill 200 people,
right? Because you're going to get
caught, right? If you're a terrorist cell,
you will get caught.
If you can't use it as a terrorist weapon,
then why have the TSA at all?
And then there was the wall web.
We will it really work and it will to
have autonomous flight. And we, we should,
we should be doing it today with
today's technology. No doubt about it.
And you could telematically operated at
each airport for the taxi part if that's
really so hard.
Um,
but anything that's that hard and then
you get to go a step further to say, well,
okay, well what about bombs? You know,
made the plane falls out of the sky.
Your luggage could fly separately in the
autonomous thing from the plane itself,
you'd have a smaller only plane.
Uh, for the actual cargo part.
You could have smaller
planes, you know, the,
the whole design space starts to change
in terms of what the optimal design is.
If you're not amortizing a pilot anymore
in terms of that operational costs.
And you could have multiple flights
where there was a single one before.
Now there's even less people per plane
and more flexibility in your roots.
All the unpacks.
And I asked them like,
have you even calculated the
economic impact of the shoe policy?
And they didn't know what I meant.
Like,
well you could just take like how much
time does that just add to the queue or
the average traveler times average salary
of the average American and just the
economic deadweight loss,
like, you know, and,
and part of what I tried to show them is
that the immune response of a system is
often worse and what kills
you not pathogen. Right?
So it's often our own immune system
that kills us literally as the method of
death. And I said, well, how long till
someone like puts a battery on fire,
you're going to keep the laptops
and cell phones off the plan.
Do you realize the economic impact of
that and they don't want to hear it.
And I was, I'm glad that it hasn't
happened quite yet, but I'm like,
that's what the terrorist cell should
be doing to cause the most harm.
Just like have one Yahoo,
make a halfassed attempt delight battery
and fire on a plane and now look what
it did do. I was like, I was in a
flight from, I want to say it was,
I mean I was in a far flung place,
but I think it was Uzbekistan to
is stumble or stumble to London.
It was one of the two.
And we actually had to surrender all of
our laptops and it created the amount of
confusion and congestion and craziness
that that created was just unbelievable.
Yeah. Yeah. So the, the end
of the TSA. That's right.
Wouldn't that be wonderful?
How do you,
how do you budget as a technology
investor for regulatory or political
opposition from incumbents? Right,
right. And you could look at,
uh, I mean many different
examples of this, whether it's uh,
lobbyists or extremely powerful unions
of various types that would be strongly,
strongly,
strongly incentivized to
not allow something like the
Tsa to no pilots' unions.
I mean, some people would point out the
uh, the, the usual like, well, you got to,
it got a bit of an issue here.
Um, so in the past and the 90s,
especially when the Internet was like,
you could just do Internet
for awhile and that was fine.
We had the mantra that never
invested in a regulated sector.
And still to this day,
try not to,
I try not to invest in
anything that requires any
law to get past in order to be
in business. The one exception is
when all in an autonomous driving,
what the product is currently illegal,
but we know it's going to become legal,
right?
Fully level five autonomous driving,
but without exception
recently and the old school,
if we not only try to avoid regular,
they did invite us.
We try to avoid if you had to deal with
in any way as a customer and a partner
with utilities or the government
or in any of that sector.
But I think frankly that left a
lot of large sectors just plump,
like a lot of entrepreneurs,
we're avoiding them like the plague.
So when Elon opened our eyes,
it says you can actually take on what
might be perceived to be the most uh,
non market if you will. Uh, you
know, or non market factors,
not like the best product doesn't
necessarily win up the military industrial
complex, right? You can take that on head
on and just win with a better product.
Right.
And similarly going up against a regulated
utilities with solar cities and like
sort of distributed solar solution.
And yes,
they're fighting with every dirty
trick you can imagine. Right?
They're trying every angle,
but sometimes there's just
such a compelling advantage
because there's been no
new injury for like 25 years.
They haven't faced a competitive
threat in their institutional lifetime.
They really don't know how to behave in
response. So you have on one hand, yes,
they'll try to do Daschle things and I
don't know what to say other than you
just kind of hope that enough of
normal democracy will flourish,
that you can overcome that and not
have critical wounds. We'll see.
But on the other side,
you don't usually know.
Like when I was in software
investing as a primary focus,
you don't usually find opportunities to
make a hundred fold or a thousandfold
cost advantage in a product, but
you do. And some of these areas,
because they literally have faced
no competitive threat for so long,
they don't even know what it's like
to compete. They take like, um,
the aerospace industry,
there's a number of Chinese ministers
who early on once basics give their
pricing for the Falcon nine, they
said, w those prices are not real.
We could not compete
at those price points.
Even if we had all of Western technology,
like it's game over and other
US competitors said, well,
we basically have to shut down
our product lines. I'm like,
imagine if some competitive oracle or
Microsoft said we're going to come out
with something like, Oh yeah,
you're right, we'd better
stop selling windows. Right.
Or we're just going to not
do databases anymore. Cause
I, yeah. That, that's better.
And I think they know,
company responds with we're shutting
down our entire product line and we were
the monopoly. Oh by the way,
with a monopolist prior,
we were the thing. Right.
And, uh, you know, you know, and, and,
and the only caveat is they say that
we're shutting down our product lines,
but government, you got to have
another company. So give us $4 billion,
we'll build a better one. We can do
it. We can build and get us $4 billion.
Like we forgot to innovate for 25 years,
but now it give us a pile of money.
We'll start. Right. It's wild. Yeah.
I never seen anything like it. Um,
so one thing that we chatted a little
bit about before recording that I wanted
to ask you about is printed
organs and synthetic meat.
So, hopefully not in the same dish
that hopefully not in the same dish.
You never know you the organ meats, the
old nose to tail. But uh, in this case,
um, you'd have to, I suppose,
imagine the exterior would be,
would be a figment of your imagination,
uh, in the case of synthetic meat.
But can you,
where are things currently with synthetic
meat and where will they be in the
relatively near term? Yeah. And why is it
important for that matter? I think it's,
that's a great question. So, um, and
the reason I think it's great as is,
I think it's one of the major tech themes
or factors that will affect a lot of
people's lives over the
next 10 to 20 years.
And not everyone is fully aware of it yet.
And it's an inevitability.
So back when we were talking about,
you know, these inevitable futures,
like all cars will be electric,
all vehicles will be autonomous.
This is one of those we will not
slaughter animals to get meat in though.
The question is, is that 50
years out is that 500 years out?
But just like we won't burn
oil and gas 500 years out,
there's just no way we would
do that in 500 years out.
Especially not in small
internal combustion engines
that we won't slaughter a
cow to get a steak.
And so the,
the insight occurs when you realize first
it's a much cheaper and efficient way
to grow the product you need without
the whole cow. Like the hide.
You don't need the methane production,
you don't need all the inefficiency.
That was an artifact of biological
evolution. You don't leave the land,
use the water,
use the energy use.
You can cut all that somewhere between
10 and a hundred x, all of those factors,
which by the way, for the, for
the listeners who don't know this,
about a third of all usable land on
earth is, goes to meet to production.
So this is the grain that gets fed to
cows and pigs and chickens and the land
that those animals live on. So like a
third of all usable land. It's astounding,
right? It's like one of the biggest
water problems, the biggest methane gas,
which is one of the most serious,
uh, greenhouse gas problems.
It's sort of on par with the whole
petrochemical economy or in another hands.
If you could say,
I will get rid of oil and gas forever
or it'll get rid of meat production,
you'd be better off getting rid of meat
production in the short term in terms of
greenhouse gases in the environment.
So pretty big, big deal. Okay.
So why is this possible?
There are two major branches of
companies that are trying to solve this.
One branch is to replace meat with
something that's not meat and there's an,
I applaud those efforts.
Um,
it's a little bit of a more of an
engineering challenge to get it past the
consumer and each product
has its own engineer.
Each and every product is challenging
and make the duck tastes like duck,
make the chicken tastes like Jagan and
have it not just be like, you know,
sausages and hotdogs,
but actually filet if you want to
take on the whole core of the market.
So that will make a meaningful impact.
And be important.
It's just gonna be slow moving because
of how hard it is to do each product and
to make it anything passable
as challenging. Extremely
hard. I mean exactly.
I've tried a lot of people been trying
every which way to do a Veggie Burger.
There's big breakthroughs recently
by using heme and plant based team.
Just like a possible, that means you get
a veggie burger that bleeds basically.
Exactly.
Cause that they found a route of soy
plant that has a molecular cage that holds
an iron atom in the center
that's called the Porphyrin.
That's the same molecule
kind of structures.
We have an hemoglobin that makes your
blood red, that makes it, you know,
turn color when it gets out of your body.
Um, that makes you right. Steak turn red,
that makes it tastes the way it does.
That makes it barbecue the way it does.
The way it browns, when you buy all
those things you put in a plant, right?
You can also put it by the way, you can
make chicken and red meat is kind of fun.
But anyway, that's the plant based
approach. It's a lot of engineering,
a lot of effort,
a lot of money per product.
The other pushes when we invested in
called Memphis meats and others like that
says let's just make steak,
let's make chicken,
let's make any of these products
in like not just the subject,
make the exact same thing
but don't grow it in account.
So it's more of a change in the
manufacturing method quite simply. Right.
Do you have the cow making the steak
or do you have it in a lab now?
How do you make it in the lab?
Well the,
the team came from cardiology and other
medical backgrounds yet people that have
done work in stem cell biology
and people have worked in,
you know the whole synthetic biology
area and it's pretty straight forward to
grow cells.
You take stem cells,
you can induce them be pluripotent or
reducing the being mortal basically and
you can just grow an infinite number of
these cells that could become anything.
They could become skeletal muscle, they
become nerves. They could become skin.
And the way you differentiate
them into skeletal muscle,
which is like our muscles and our arms
is you put them on a scaffold that causes
them to differentiate into that kind
of thing. A scaffold that is um,
it's an edible gelatin like thing kind of,
you know,
it's basically some other food products
and things like we had college in and
other stuff you have the
scaffold is things Arrow Gel.
The cells differentiate and they merged
together and he's long fibers just like
our muscle cells.
So what were formerly discreet stand
on the cells form into one long multi
multinucleated cell. It
twitches, it does everything.
Like a normal muscle is a muscle cell.
That species where I have tasted the duck,
but most recently,
so it's duck muscle and over time you
can add the irregularities of sinew and
all this very, now it's just like a
perfect cut of duck muscle. You know,
the mouthfeel everything. It's just the
same thing. Everything's a filet Mignon.
Exactly. By the way, in the
future, you can make it healthier.
You can make it all a mega three
rich oils. You could tune things,
but let's just start with a simple,
don't confuse the market with it's,
it's not Turducken, it's Turkey
arts dog. It's not a blend.
But you imagine blending
is like a simple thing.
Like there's no reason you
can do infinite blending,
like blending a wine and make
it just the right mouthfeel,
just the right whatever.
Right? So, but in their term,
let's not jump ahead of ourselves.
It's just a substitute.
And you can do this in
small, like, you know,
like a Chinese shipping
container kind of things.
You could put this near
the point of consumption.
You could have this in urban areas and
you're not shipping meet all around the
country is growing the steak,
you know,
sort of to order the end cost
point should be much, much lower.
And so to me this had one of those sort
of lightning bolt moments of this is the
inevitable future. There's no technical
risks that says this couldn't happen.
There isn't like we have to
invent some that element.
There's a lot of system engineering, the
optimize it, the feed stocks, you know,
whatever. That's it. You know,
spilling the right reactor size,
it's gonna take some engineering,
but it's not going to
take breakthrough science.
It's the same epiphany that when
I first wrote in an electric car,
when I first had an autonomous ride early
on with the Google ones, uh, you know,
the, the old, uh, is that they had an
automated, it's like this is the future.
Like you could,
you could just see it like a clarion
bell ringing in your head and then a few
implications started the head like,
wow, this will transform the world.
And a lot of ways the amount of land
and resources and real estate plays that
relayed to me production today. Not
to mention, oh, mad cow disease,
influenza h one n one,
all these other things that we don't like,
those collaterals that the climate has
of the food industry and we haven't
gotten to that. Um, you can see how we'll
get from here to there that the buyers,
the largest buyers of meat
would absolutely like to
diversify their supply chain.
So they are not vulnerable
to and for sure,
or mad cower or any other
disruption of their supply chain,
you can see how they're going to want
to feather that in. So by the way,
Tyson and Cargill,
two larges me companies in America
invested in this company as well as in the
series a with us. And um, but then
I realized something about myself,
I realized for the first time something
where my future self will condemn my
present self is immoral. Yeah. Right.
So I know that 50 years from now,
once I'm eating the bacon and stake
that is not killed an animal and its
production, will I be able to visit
a slaughterhouse for the first time?
I W I won't do that today.
I like eating meat so much that I
refused to go visit a slaughterhouse.
In fact of the USTA meat inspectors,
they,
99% of them become vegetarian.
They don't start that way.
It's like if you see how it's made, you
wouldn't need it. And yet I won't do that.
And,
and when I say moral,
I think our humanity circle of empathy
expands over time. You know, first it was,
you know, family unit and the
tribes and the nation state,
then maybe global citizens. Now I think
the Inter species, if you will, um,
empathy is inevitable trajectory
where I would welcome that.
That would just be more thoughtful
about other sending organisms and their
wellbeing that we just
look right past today.
It's kind of like being a slave owner
in America back in the 17 hundreds, eh,
the economy depends on it.
I don't want to ask questions
about how those slave ships,
like I'm sure slave owners didn't
visit slave ships in the few that did.
And we're like, oh my God,
we've got to change this. Right?
You just don't want to look.
And when you had the,
once you have the economic alternative
that doesn't have any money,
any compromises, it's not like, oh, it's
not really bacon or it's not really stake.
It's the same thing. Just no animal
died. Then you'll have the moral shift.
I think profoundly we're, what
is the current state? I mean,
what products do they have that they're
still in development because of the cost
side at scale.
So sure that this company's so,
so when I mentioned the challenge
of the plant based substitutes,
is engineering something
that people mistake? I mean
the, the the taste as good.
That's the key engineering challenge here.
The whole thing is just cost cause
you can make something that's
indistinguishable you, it just
costs too much right now. Right.
And there's three vectors are making it
cheaper too are like total gimmes and
one just was engineering.
The gimmes are just making a bigger plant.
So if you say you brew beer,
if you just have a one liter of facility
on your desktop at home and you're
amortize the cost of your home to
make one liter of beer at a time,
it's gonna be expensive liter of beer,
even if the formula is the same
as a production planner. So scale.
The second is a cheaper feed. Stocks just
feed it something other than the very,
very expensive serum.
Using analogies in RND
purposes to minimize variables
using pharmaceutical grade
inputs to the sort of feed the cells
if you will. What do they feed them?
It's like a glucose mixture
with amino acids, like a
ceremony, like a blood serum.
It's kind of like what you'd find in
your blood doesn't make your blood cells
live, you know? Wow. So, uh,
it's a variety stuff that's
used for very research purposes,
but there's no reason it couldn't be that.
But the reason it doesn't exist,
there's no market for
food grade, uh, you know,
plant based feedstocks that
cells can grow off of. Um,
and now we have a good reason to do
that. And then the third is just, uh,
various engineering optimizations on
the cells and the mixtures and like what
combinations of cells do you want
to try to boost the fat content?
They've each cell or have
separate, you know, muscle and fat.
Do you want to have it all be like
one, you know, one bite does all,
or do you want to have two different
types, you know? Well, I mean, if you,
a few thoughts occurred to me as
you're describing this. The first is,
would this company,
would this company utilize
the,
the technology to produce human tissue,
uh,
for regenerative medicine
or other purposes? And then
I thought to myself, wow,
you could also, you could become
a moral cannibal if you wanted,
like you could produce,
not that you would want it to
produce human burgers and eat them,
but you could ostensibly do that. But that
was just more of a thought. I was like,
wow, that's, that's, that's well,
you could also that small
donor to revive and restore,
which is trying to bring back
the mammoth and extinct species,
he could go back to have the
mammoth. That's true. That's true.
Without growing the mammoth.
Yeah, that's right. Yeah. The
little Panini Ganey, it's,
this really gave me the
brand burger brand. Uh,
but, uh, it, is that maybe
a, just a distraction or,
I don't know the technology well enough
to think of it from a, from a, from a, uh,
from a medical, human medical
is a good question. Yes.
The first sort of clean meat
or alternative meat company
that I came across was
using, ironically, the
reverse sequence, which is,
it spun out of a company that was doing
Oregon's, they'd printed bladders.
There's a kid I met who's
name is 18 years old.
He's lived with a grown bladder
for many years now. Um, and, and,
but that was more like a three d printer.
So when you're growing a specific Oregon
that needs to be functional, it's super,
super important to get a lot
of the details right. Um, a
chunk of skeletal muscle,
you know what, if you just take it from
the center piece versus the end with sin,
you, you know, there's variation.
If you want to make it function like a
muscle and the connection to your sinews
and what have you is you're making crown
beef from scratching just a chunk of
meat out of the middle.
It's just a chunk of meat.
So do you have much bigger challenges
with the printed Oregon's that lent itself
naturally to a three d printer
kind of approach and it,
and it works wonderfully for some organs.
They've been going kidneys and they're
some of the connective tissue stuff
around the reconstructive surgery,
um, for the face and what have you.
But it's slow and it's also great example
of personalized one on one marketing.
Like you want to go cells
that are compatible with
your body. So that you know,
they would source of your stem cells
to grow year Oregon for you. And it's,
it's kind of a different approach and a
number of ways intuitively from what you
want to mass produce for consumption,
where you could just have, you know,
who cares where the cal,
it could all be the same cow clone that
you're growing the B from where every
human implant wants to be a immune,
uh, compatible with what you've got.
So the spinout didn't make as
much sense to me to say, well,
let's try to produce metric tons of
meat using that three d printer. Again,
any sense of a three d printer?
And I'm sure they're gonna figure
out some way to scale that up.
But I just felt like, to me there was a
definite technology risks there. Just,
I couldn't see the hand
waving argument says,
why is that gonna get a thousand
times better if for sure it could,
but I don't see why it has to. It
might not. Whereas this other thing,
growing cells in a VAT inherently scales,
it's like just have a bigger fat.
It's like it's three d to start with.
It's not a tutee lettering.
There's something about the manufacturing
method I guess that's been borne out
and things like brewing beer and in a
variety of fermentation tasks where you
kind of understand how to generate metric
tons of stuff with the fermentation.
For people listening like
myself who are not particularly,
uh,
I'm being generous,
not technically trained,
I'm certainly not an
engineer by any stretch, uh,
who want to make themselves
more scientifically literate.
Are there any books or resources or
approaches that you would recommend?
Yeah,
there's two things that jumped to mind.
One is the general purpose
overview of what's important.
Almost like a survey level where if
you're just a business executive and you
want to make sure you're not blindsided
by some development that may be relevant
than not be a practitioner. And then
there could be a question of, well,
is there something that like
let's say you're a farmer,
autonomous vehicle driver and now
you're looking for the next thing,
like what might you want to study to
engage in the economy as a practitioner?
And there are some areas that are more,
I think easily approached to another.
So on the,
so first than the overall survey,
I think there are some writers who do
a good job bringing you with a sort of
overview mentality too.
Like what's really going on in the world.
People like Kevin Cavey, Kevin Kelly, um,
and maybe Matt Ridley and maybe,
um, and a few others like this, uh,
going back with Hostetler and
good electric Bach. There's,
there's been a variety,
but I might highlight,
let's say Kevin Kelly. Yeah.
Because the single book that's had the
most influence on me and my entire life
is one of his earlier ones
called out of control.
And it really started my lifelong
fascination of the biological metaphors in
technology.
Everything from all that stuff we're
talking about earlier about selling
automata and iterative
algorithms and evolution is
itself an iterative algorithm.
The power of evolution, the power of
genetic engineering, all this stuff.
So he was ahead of his time.
He wrote this book last century and it
recently got translated to mandarin and
it's just in the current days,
one of those is probably the most
popular books in China today,
even though he wrote it decades ago.
Um,
because it's actually very relevant today.
So that'd be a good starting point.
I think it segues into the technology
that either as a practitioner or just you
can read about this. Um, if
you just direct yourself,
either simple Google searches or there's
the particular book I point out just to
learn about deep learning,
learning about, and y'all networks.
The reason I say that is I've never seen
a greater demand for a technology and a
scarcity of supply,
like the salaries being afforded through
the engineers in this area or out of
control, you know, half a
million dollars for beginners.
Who are some of the more credible thinkers
or practitioners who talk publicly
about deep learning? Uh, let me
think. Yeah, I'm trying to think.
There's a good overview that the places,
well I know that Coursera and some of
these places are trying and I'm Sebastian
runs a,
um,
you'd acidy are trying to do deep learning
courses and such as an intro and I
haven't taken those. I don't know how good
they, I would imagine even some of the,
the very technical people have given
non technical talks or whether it's at
Google or elsewhere. I would imagine
some of the thinkers that might be, uh,
in their day to day work way too technical
or specialized. I've probably given,
this is a tough one,
maybe for your show notes,
I can try to come up with something.
So part of the challenge I had is
because I started a phd in this,
I didn't seek the generic.
Right.
And I've been reading once in the
back of my hand, I'm like, well,
is that too technical? But I bet
you I can dig some up. Yeah, sure.
And it may sound self serving,
but I've tried to give some of those talks
and when I go to conferences a number
of times, there's a real dearth of other
people doing that same summarization.
But I would say that, uh,
the group out of Canada,
so everything from Hinton to Yoshua
Bengio oil to Andrew Ng who's coming back,
coming back to the u s in his
case they are both of you know,
leading edge of R and D and and such
and they give really good talks.
It's just not all of them.
Some of them are deeply technical,
some of them are overview.
So I'll try to find other for you.
Some examples of toxic gave that are for
the average person. Perfect. Perfect.
So that's, that's what we'll do.
Then the last thing I want to say,
but if someone actually
wants to get into it,
is it's actually remarkably easy to learn.
When I said it's weird,
the labor market arbitrage is,
I don't think it takes more than six
to eight months to become really domain
expert in this.
And you don't have to be spectacularly
good at computer science before you,
the background is, it's just so different
from normal computer science. Yeah.
That arguably a new entrant has a great
opportunity to just learn how these
things are trained and forget about normal
computer science. And you know, I can,
uh, I can say a few things
in response to that.
The first is to recommend
people check out.
So we talked about Tim urban a little
earlier and the tail end and so on.
So I had Tim urban on this podcast and
I asked him how he got up to speed on
topics and he went through his exact,
he just
laid it out to them, just calls
you call the guru on the mountain,
just calls you on the, for
those people interested,
if they just search Tim Ferriss show
Tim Urban, that'll pop right up.
And he spends about 20 minutes talking
about exactly this, getting up to speed,
which, which should be I think
helpful for a lot of folks. Uh,
and then in the show
notes at tim.blog/podcast,
you can just find this and we'll have
some additional resources for people who
want to include myself, uh, dig
into this and learn, learn more.
Uh, have you ever given a kid will be
maybe the last question or second to last
question. Have you ever given a
commencement speech? Oh, funny.
You should ask once for my high school
and it was the most terrifying thing I've
ever done. Like, like
I love public speaking.
I did debate back in high school and
when I'm speaking to an audience that
somewhat similar to the
audiences I've spoken to before,
check if it's on subjects that I've spoken
about before, check is my power alley.
I don't mind that.
Oh my God.
Trying to be relevant to a
bunch of 18 year olds. Uh Wow.
That was, that was back in Dallas.
Yeah. But I did that for years back.
What did you talk with? Did you talk about
what did, and maybe if, if it's broad,
what did people respond most strongly
to of what you told them? Oh,
I can actually give you the shownotes.
I managed to keep a copy and someone even
translated in Spanish. Oh yeah. Great.
So I'm trying to remember what it was.
I was trying to,
well here's it was the advice I got that
really helped was think about when you
were their age and the more time I spend
thinking about what life was like with
me, for me as a senior exes,
I went to that same school,
it all sort of clicked into place.
The, what do I want to do with my life,
what's going on in the world?
And sort of weaving what I was learning
from much capital and all the amazing
entrepreneurs that I was seeing to convey
to them like why you are entering the
most exciting period of human history.
And I shared a little bit about things
we spoke about on this podcast around
things going on in synthetic biology,
things going on in AI and what have you.
Each of these areas is
so rich with opportunity.
And I gave him some general advice about
just thinking about your career as a
pursuit of passion, thinking about
what you're uniquely good at,
that no one else in your random
walk through life may have done.
And to keep that in mind as you hopefully
infuse with a bit of technical open
mindedness and creativity
and childlike mind,
an exploration of what you want to do,
that they're just like,
it's no better time to be entering the
world and trying to make a difference.
I tried to encourage them a
lot to think entrepreneurially,
to think about being change
agents for the world.
That everything that history books we've
written about it is some new entrants
entering a field they didn't
know much about prior. Um,
and encouraging them that this is what
increasingly defines the world we live in.
You know,
one,
one question is somebody post to me
when I was considering the question,
we're considering unique strengths.
I was like,
I don't know if I have unique strengths.
I do a lot of things kind of well,
but I'm not sure. Yeah, maybe that's it.
Maybe it's the pattern
matching across those.
And the question that they asked
me was, what are, what are you,
what do you find easy that some that
a lot of your friends find hard?
And I was like, Huh. And that actually
ended up being very helpful, uh,
question for somewhat indirectly landing
on the strengths because I had a lot of
trouble with that. Um, so maybe folks
find that five is a good question.
That helpful.
Yeah,
because everyone does have
some acid element to that
question and they also have
something they've done that back to that
early question when I was in an venture
capital, well, how am I different from
every other venture capitalist who's,
you know, trying to do this job. There's
something about your personal background.
It could be a language
skill. It could be, wow,
you had to take care of an aging
grandmother in your youth and you,
so you have a sympathy and empathy for
what the age are going through that
others lack.
Like that actually could be a
superhero strength if you want to be an
entrepreneur for this aging demographic of
baby boomers, uh, not everyone. In fact,
very few entrepreneurs
think about the agent,
for example.
And I think you and your unique strength
can also be an unusual combination of
two strengths, right? I've heard
of Marc Andreessen talk about, uh,
layering public speaking on top of
anything else and separating yourself.
Warren Buffet would say
something very similar. Uh,
Scott Adams of Dilbert
famous talked about this.
Let's say you have an unusual
combination, right? So maybe you have,
that's exactly double degree and
then you have an Mba that's right.
And then you know how to debate.
You don't have to be the best at
the world at any of those things.
There's a lot of wisdom there
because it's that pairing
that,
anyway,
that's I think why most scientific
breakthroughs are interdisciplinary.
There are someone outside of the field
of chemistry working with someone maybe
in the field to come with a breakthrough,
not someone at the core of, again,
an academic discipline.
And this is why universities are such
areas of foment of innovation is because
they have all the disciplines
and the one physical campus.
But if you just had a chemistry
department or just the chemistry college,
it wouldn't make world breaking changes.
Right.
The people who figured
out the structure of DNA,
we're like an orange theologists and a
physicist, not chemists, right? Yeah.
Crystallographers we'll actually,
Roseland parks needs to get credit
and it was going to shout out to her.
So she's the traditionalist
in that regard.
But more and more people think about Elan,
not domain expert entering a new domain.
It's the cross pollination, right?
Being let's say software design with
LEDs to the aerospace industry or
[inaudible] Griffey into
personal computers. Exactly.
And so that pairing I think hearkens back
to one other thought that might bring
this whole thing full circle,
which is every great idea is
a recombination prior ideas.
This is a a really powerful and simple
idea that was popularized in three
different books at the same time,
which I think is Metta ironic that their
argument at the same time as every good
idea that happens around the same time.
And the reason that's interesting is
you can think in history of Edison and
Tesla and Marconi is like the time was
ripe given the breakthroughs that had
just having electricity,
magnetism to think about AC induction
motors and radio and everything else got
invented by all those same people are all
within months of each other today writ
large.
We have many more ideas.
We have the Internet allowing us to
cross pollinate ideas like never before.
These two things that are unique to you,
Paul on it together,
the calligraphy and the, you know,
computer design for jobs or what have you.
The number of possible pairings is growing
common editorially and I think that's
why we have accelerating
change technology.
That's why Moore's law exists
over such a long timeframe.
It's not because of the
semiconductor industry,
it's because the number of idea pairings
is growing as a to the end factor
called Reed's law with the
number of ideas and the planet.
And once you break down the barriers
between formerly discrete academic
disciplines and strip all that vernacular
way of their independent ways of
communicating with each
other that are so isolating.
And you see the common
patterns like wait isn't,
that's just like a information theory I
saw there and then my on the microbial
design front,
it's like then that same problems,
all these rich array of new ideas
is a sort of Meta reasonably,
you can't really quantify
how strongest would be.
We'll probably see more innovation than
ever before and it's not just because we
all will see more innovation than
ever before. It's because it's common,
it's real explosion of idea parents is
happening globally and oh by the way,
it's about to explode when the next 4
billion people come online and we go from
two to 6 billion people online because
of satellite broadband that space x and
others are developing. That's all coming
in the next five years. Like Holy Shit,
we're going to have a just explosion idea,
possibilities and innovation across the
plant. Exciting time to be alive. Exactly.
Especially when you have quantum
computers accessing potentially parallel
universes. It's right and where does
it end? It doesn't. Uh, well, Steve,
thank you so much for taking the time
and as soon as a really fun and a is
meandering is as the path I forged.
Hopefully you had fun as well and
to be continued. Hopefully we have,
we have many more conversations. Uh,
and I've saw any more questions for you.
So another fortunate for another time,
but where can people find you online to
say hello? See what you're up to? Sure.
So on Facebook I'm just username
Jurvetson and flicker username.
Jurvetson uh,
those are the ones,
that's the ones I like most of my old
writings or like the old stuff going back
2004 is mostly on flicker. And then
my social network addiction does your,
is Facebook and what is next
for you? What's next? Oh,
I'm going to start a new venture
fund some point this year. Um,
I haven't picked the name yet,
but I'm bouncing some ideas around
to focus entirely on purpose driven
businesses with really long timeframes
where we never sell a share.
At least I don't. And, um, we, uh,
we'll be investing in the kinds of
things we've talked about today,
companies that hopefully history books
we've written about companies whose
founders have a purpose greater than
their own life on this planet in a purpose
greater than certainly
making a quick buck.
And there are more opportunities and
more industry sectors and I've ever seen
but not as if he's seen the 90s.
It was like software semiconductors
in life sciences. That was it.
Like I never imagined I would invest
and just [inaudible] dot com [inaudible]
horribly wrong for a while.
Just balls and all being the
pinnacle or the Nadir of, of uh,
intellectual curiosity.
But now it's just a flourishing,
coral reef was innovation everywhere and
incredibly interesting tiny investing
startups. Well, can't wait to
see you do next. Thank you.
And to everybody listening,
there will be plenty of links in the show
notes including the things we promised
a resources to deep
learning and much more.
And you can check that out at
tim.blog/podcast and as well always.
Thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again. Just a few more
things before you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by helix sleep.
Last year I committed to
making sleep a top priority,
trying to fix onset insomnia or
continuing to fix that depth of sleep,
quality of sleep.
I tracked a lot.
I tested a lot and I revisited really
everything from daily routine to the
surfaces that slept on, playing
with the chilly pad, whatever.
And when I moved to Austin I got all new
beds including mattresses from Helix,
working with the world's leading sleep,
certainly some of them he looked sleep,
develop mattresses personalized to your
preferences and sleep style to make sure
that you can have the best sleep
possible without costing thousands upon
thousands of dollars.
He looked.
Sleep has recently added a new layer to
customize sleep with the helix pillow
you all.
New pillows are fully adjustable so you
can achieve perfect comfort regardless
of a sleep physician or body type
or if you're a shifty type like me,
I move around quite a bit when I sleep.
Just take their simple two to three
minute sleep quiz to get started and that
will help ensure that they can build a
mattress or pillow that you will love the
mattress, whatever this be spoke
mattresses that you arrive at. Uh,
we'll get to you within a week and
the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress for 100
nights and if not completely happy,
they'll pick it up and
offer a full refund.
I tested that refund policy because I
test all of these sponsors and kick the
tires a lot.
We tested it and they came through on
making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body.
Type to personalize your sleep experience,
visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you'll
receive up to $125 off your mattress
order. That's helix sleep, h,
e l I x sleep.com forward slash
Tim for up to $125 off your order.
This episode is brought
to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic
for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those
clever finish founders.
And when I first mentioned
that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week,
it lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite
side of the spectrum of new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir
to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for
decades. I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey
brain has never been easy.
It still isn't easy very often and I
found Reishi which had been fascinated by
for a few years now has been very,
very effective and calming
their old formula, however,
four Sigmadek old formula included
Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons
and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys, I would love to experiment
with this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without
sweeteners if you'd be open to it.
Too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game
for experimentation and
so they created a special
custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio looks or comes in single
serving packets which are perfect for
traveling.
In fact,
I'm about to leave the country right
now and I have a packet in front of me
that's just going to sit in
the end of my carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy
that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and I'll
give you my take quote, a warning.
For those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine,
so if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or
nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say,
no,
you should suck it up and you should
drink the tea because it's not that fitter
and maybe should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
young ins. When they
say, well, I'm sure cool.
Which means you're not
able to eat bitterness.
Bitter is in many cases and indication
of things that help liberty toxification
and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio,
Letcher on family members,
on friends, everybody has liked it. It's
a little bit or the, it's not that hard,
so I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put him honey or nut milk or any
of that shit. Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious. I think if you like poo
air, that kind of stuff, that type of tea,
you're going to dig it. So just
try it. Okay. Back to then my read.
If you'd like to naturally improve
your sleep, both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just
enjoy this reishi elixir without any
sweeteners. It has organic, Reishi
extract, organic fueled, mint extract,
organic rose hips extract, organic
Tulsi extract, and that's it.
No fancy stuff, no artificial watching
McCall it anything. So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com
forward slash Ferriss and get
20% off this special batch.
I don't know if they're gonna
be making much more of this, uh,
it since it was made specifically for
you guys to do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be
open to experimenting with
me to create products for
you guys. Specifically, check it out
for Sigmadek. That's Flur, s, I, g, m,
and t I c. Dot com forward
slash Ferris, F, e, r, R.
I s s. Get 20% off this
special batch. And, uh,
you must use the code of
Ferris to receive a discount.
FBR Our ISS.
So again,
go to foursigmatic.com
forward slash Ferris and then
use code Ferris for 20% off
of this rare,
exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir
for nighttime routines without any
sweeteners in June.